Hai cái em coi lại cái các nhóm mình coi
lại cái ý tưởng đồ án môn học của mình,
lát hồi mình sẽ học nội dung mới xong rồi.
Tôi sẽ hướng dẫn tiếp về cái phần bài các
bước tiếp theo của bài đào án cũng như là
song song đó là các bài thực hành ở các
bước tương đương sau cái phần hướng dẫn
đó thì nhóm nào mà các em chưa có rõ.
Thấy về cái đồ án của mình cần trao đổi
trước khi mình xác định cái phạm vi và
mình triển khai thì mình sẽ trao đổi và
cuối buổi ha xong buổi ngày hôm nay là
mình sẽ sau buổi ngày hôm nay á.
Ở theo lịch trình thì.
Buổi học tiếp theo của mình đúng vào dịp
lễ nên cô sẽ báo nghỉ và báo bù với một
buổi nên mình sẽ có một thời gian dài để
mình chuẩn bị cho các cái bước được hướng
nhận trong bài thực hành và đồ án và đây
là các cái bước đầu tiên để.
Mình xác định phần thi đề tài và phương
thức thực hiện nên nếu lúc này mình sai
thì các bước còn lại cũng sẽ bị hưởng
theo nên phần này cũng sẽ dành thêm một
buổi.
Báo cáo tiến trình dịch vụ bộ báo cáo
tiến trình cho các cái bước mình đã được
hướng dẫn của đồng án và thực hành trong
buổi tiếp theo ha nên lát hồi vào cuối
buổi á cái em coi là bài của mình.
Rồi lát rồi mình học xong rồi,
cuối buổi mình sẽ trao đổi cái chỗ nào
không rõ thì cái em trao đổi trước khi
mình thực hiện cái phần đó á với lại chắc
mình cũng sẽ đợi cái thành viên khác vào
đầy đủ luôn thì mình bắt đầu khoảng 15
phút.
Chơi game tới 18 giờ 30 mới bắt đầu nhé.
A cái mình bắt đầu học với do cái tuần
sau mình nghĩ là ấy,
mình chọn một buổi để mình học bù trong
tuần sau. Ngày 3 lớp mình có,
tối ngày 3 là lớp mình có trùng địch với
môn nào không?
Tối ngày 3 tháng 9 là hết nghỉ lễ.
Năm mang chính là thứ 5 để không có gì
không trùng nữa.
Đúng rồi, thứ 5,
vậy mình rời lịch học từ ngày 31 sang
ngày 3 tháng 9 ha.
Cái cô thông báo lên rút lớp luôn ở trên
tim luôn. Cảm ơn cái.
Không trùng lịch, học bù,
học của môn khác là được.
Còn nếu mà bạn nào mà lúc đó có lịch
trùng lịch riêng thì các em có thể xem là
video hết các em.
Rồi cô đã cập nhật cái lịch dạy bù thông
báo nghỉ và lịch dạy bù của mình.
Vào ngày 3 tháng 9,
mức 18 giờ 15 cũng giờ này hả em và đã
thông báo cho bên trung tâm rồi.
Kem nhớ chú ý là thật bù và lịch nghỉ của
mình.
Rồi hôm nay mình sẽ học tiếp nội dung
tiếp theo.
Hôm nay cô sẽ dạy tiếp về cái nội dung
chương 4 của mình, về phần mềm hệ thống,
phần mềm ứng dụng để các em hiểu các khái
niệm về những cái thành phần trong hệ
thống phần mềm của mình và các đều lưu ý
khi.
Mà mình lên kế hoạch đầu tư cái thành
phần phần mềm này cho cơ quan ha.
Sau đó là mình sẽ tới cái phần hướng dẫn
thực hiện đồ án cũng như hướng dẫn thực
hiện thực hành cho các bước tiếp theo.
Rồi.
Cô sẽ làm bài tập, cái này cô có giao,
cô có mở cái assigment trên.
Elonin cho phần rồi và cái bài tập aside
trong đó là hai cái phần tìm hiểu về giai
đoạn đầu cho bài đồ án và thực hành.
Nên tới cái buổi tiếp theo á là mình báo
cáo tiến trình thực chất là kem dịch báo
cáo về cái nội dung bài tập.
Cô gia về nhà ngày hôm nay ở các nhóm để
tham gia báo cáo và để cô xem coi cái kế
hoạch và phạm vi thực hiện ban đầu của
mình có ổn hay không.
Và nếu nó ổn rồi thì các cái nội dung
tiếp theo thì các em có thể tự tìm hiểu
và làm về các bước.
Thường không ứng dụng cái phần lý thuyết
mình học để vô cái dự án đầu dự án đầu tư
của mình cũng như dự án phát triển phần
mềm lát hồi nãy cô có cho thời gian các
em coi lại bài á thì lúc mà mình.
Coi cái phần hướng dẫn ngày hôm nay có
chỗ nào mà cây không rõ thì các em có sao
một phần thì tôi sẽ ở lại cho các em đặt
câu hỏi để các em biết cách mình làm về
cái bài thực hành chế đồ án thì các em
trao đổi vào lúc đó luôn.
Thì có vấn đề gì thì mình trao đổi trực
tiếp hơn thì nó sẽ thuận tiện hơn là việc
nhắn tin cô sẽ hiểu rõ cái em nói và cô
phản hồi nó cũng nhanh và các em cũng
đánh giá được các em hiểu chỗ nào để mình
trao đổi,
nắm các cách phương thức làm việc.
Rồi tới.
Tới buổi tiếp theo thì mình sẽ báo cáo
tiến trần hơn.
Lúc báo cáo tiến trình về những nội dung
mình thực hiện được. Ha.
Rồi hôm nay phần chương 4 của mình về hệ
thống của phần mình ứng dụng.
Cái này là cũng nội dung khá là quen
thuộc.
Chỉ có một số khái niệm có thể là nó hơi
lạ với mình thôi.
Nhưng phần lớn thì nó không quá khó và
các.
Có thể hình dung về cái thành phần phần
mềm trong cơ sở hạ tầng công nghệ thông
tin.
Khi mô mình đầu tư phát triển cho doanh
nghiệp thì mình sẽ gồm có những thành
phần gì và mình có những thành phần nào
sẽ nên thiết kế.
Thì bức tranh tổng thể đối với một cái hệ
thống phần mềm là đầu tiên là em sẽ phải
biết về 2 cái này.
Người dùng và nghiệp vụ.
Cái này nó giống như cái phần hướng dẫn
bài tập thực hành phát triển hệ thống
phần mềm có ứng.
Sử dụng công nghệ mới,
các em dù các em có ứng dụng công nghệ
mới gì đi chăng nữa thì thứ nhất là các
em còn phải biết hệ thống phần mềm này
của em dành cho người dùng nào và cái thứ
hai là nó phục vụ cho nghiệp vụ gì của
người dùng đó.
Ủa nhóm người dùng đó.
Nếu mà mình đi sau các môn tiếp theo mà
các em học thì nếu mà mình học đúng đi
chuyên về hệ thống phần mềm á thì thường
là mình sẽ học về các môn phân tích tiếp
hệ thống thông tin rồi tới cái.
Nhà thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu rồi phát triển
hệ thống phần mềm.
Thì khi mà các em phân tích,
thiết kế hệ thống thông tin muốn phát
triển hệ thống phần mềm thì các em cần
phải biết là mình phân tích cái hệ thống
thông tin.
Cần xác định được những nhóm người dùng
mình sẽ xây dựng các phần mềm cho những
nhóm người dùng nào và phục vụ cho những
cái nghiệp vụ gì?
Thường là mình sẽ phải vẽ các cái biểu đồ
phân tích,
thiết kế và vẽ các cái lưu đồ để mình
hình dung xong cái luồng xử lý của hệ
thống phần mềm.
Sau đó là mình sẽ triển khai để đáp ứng
cái nghiệp vụ thực tế.
Ví dụ giống như cái nghiệp vụ của mình.
Mình xây dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm quản
lý chất lượng giáo dục dành cho phòng
trai pháp chế đi chẳng hạn thì em phải
biết nhóm người dùng của mình tham gia ở
đây là sẽ có nhân viên phần trăm pháp chế
chẳng hạn nè giảng viên.
À giảng viên phụ trách hoặc là bên ngoài
của khoa và cái quy trình về các cái nội
dung mà người ta muốn quản lý giống như
là quản lý quá trình đăng ký học phần,
quản lý quá trình giảng dạy, quản lý.
Tài nguyên giảng dạy quản lý hoạt động
giảng dạy rồi quản lý kết quả giảng dài
chẳng hạn thì mình cần phải nắm rõ các
nghiệp vụ mà mình cần thiết để khi mình
xây dựng để mình làm theo thì khi mà các
em đầu tư.
Cái thể đầu tư cái nhiều hơn là đầu tư
toàn bộ cái thành phần phần mềm hay là
các em trong bà đồ án hay là các em chỉ
phát triển cái hệ thống phần mềm.
À.
Ở phần vi nhỏ hơn giống như bài thực hành
thì các em cũng phải xác định những nhóm
người dùng và nghiệp vụ ở đây của mình.
Thì đối với chính xác,
còn ngoài ra còn cái phần mà vẽ vẽ cái
biểu đồ hoặc là các em làm ấy thì ở đây
cô khuyến khích á.
Cô biết gần đây là ứng dụng AI,
nó hỗ trợ các em vẽ biểu đồ rất là nhiều.
Nhưng nó vẽ thì nó sẽ phát sinh ra,
nhìn thì có vẻ logic nhưng người có
chuyên môn đọc vào.
Thì người ta sẽ biết cái đó là của hình
AI severay thì nó sẽ phát sinh ra những
lỗi nhỏ mà các cái loại tác vụ này chỉ có
những người nào mà mình thật sự học vì nó
và các em tiến hành phân tích,
xác định các cái thành phần luồng thì
mình mới sẽ phát hiện. Còn nếu mà.
Mình chưa có kiến thức chuyên môn nhiều
về nó thường là các em sẽ thấy kết quả
khá là đẹp. Nhìn vô nó rõ ràng.
Nhưng mà bạn nào đã từng triển khai đã
làm rồi thì sẽ thấy.
Nó có nhiều cái lỗ hổng và nhiều cái tư
duy logic nó không hợp lý,
ngay cả các bạn sinh viên chính quy cũng
đã từng dùng đó để vẽ nhanh cho cho cái
phần thực hành tại cái phần cho cái đồ ăn
khóa luận của các ổ khóa luận tốt nghiệp
của các bạn mặc dù là.
Nhưng mà cái đó là bị sẽ được bị giảng
viên la và bị sửa nha, không có,
không có dùng tại vì lúc mà cô không nhận
thì cô thấy có nhiều bạn giao giao tiến
độ cho các bạn làm thì các bạn làm không
có thời gian làm với lại có cái thể là
các bạn chuyên về datason thì.
Phần và phần mềm nó chỉ là một cái
prototype demo của các bạn thôi nên các
bạn làm lướt qua cái giai đoạn này thì
nhưng mà cô la và các cái nếu mà các
giảng viên khác cô nghỉ cũng sẽ la.
Vì nó phát sinh vẽ về cái quy trình
nghiệp vụ của người dùng,
nó không có hợp lý.
Và sai nhưng mà nó chuyện đó có một cái
hay là nhìn bề ngoài,
nó sẽ rất là đẹp và cái có nhìn thì có vẻ
là logic nếu mà nhìn ngon kỹ nên nó dẫn
đến tình trạng là cái người vẽ thì sẽ
thấy nó hay nhưng mà tới cái người chấm
thì nhìn vô là người thấy biết là nó có
vấn đề và thường.
Là các ba em sẽ bị đánh điểm từ điểm nặng
và đánh rớt ở chỗ này rất là nhiều.
Vâng,
và quay lại cái phần này thì nếu mà trong
cái bài thực hành của các em ở đây,
cái bài thực hành của mình nghĩa là
thuyết minh,
nhưng mà trong cái phần thuyết minh thì
nó cũng có một cái mục là kết quả nghiên
cứu sơ khởi.
À thì có một vài xu hướng là các bạn sinh
viên hoặc là các bạn mà các em dưới trước
minh đề tài phát triển hệ thống phần mềm
á thì các bạn có kết quả phân tích nghiệp
vụ, cơ quả ban đầu thì các bạn hay bỏ vào.
Thì cô khuyến khích là cái đó là các em
nên hiểu cái nghiệp vụ của mình để vẽ vào.
Chứ không phải là mình sử dụng các cái
ngôn độc phân tích mà nó vẽ mà phải hiểu
luôn là Covid có một số cái phần mềm nó
vẽ theo cái nguyên tắc của nó chứ không
phải vẽ theo cái dựa trên công cụ phân
tích tích hệ thống thông tin.
Nên nó không theo cái một cái quy định
của một cái sơ đồ nào cả. Ví dụ,
giống như vẽ sơ đồ UK vô đồ Lazda Ram
hoặc là silconna gram,
nó có nguyên tắc vẽ.
Nhưng mà mình vẽ bằng công cụ gây ai thì
nó giống như một cái bản hỗn tạp vậy đó.
Nó không có theo nguyên tắc nào cả.
Và nhưng mà lúc đầu thì cái em,
nếu mà em không kỹ thì các em cứ nghĩ là
nó hay và các em cứ nghĩ là ờ mình vẽ rồi,
tại sao mình lại không có điểm nhưng mà
đôi khi nó sẽ làm các em mất điểm nha.
Ở đây thì cô chấm bài nhiều thì cô thấy
cái người ta đòi sai thì cô nhắc trước cả
cái nhóm.
Ở đây mình hãy hiểu là.
Công cụ ai nó chỉ là công cụ và cái người
kiểm soát và chịu trách nhiệm và coi cái
hệ thống đó có thể triển khai được không
là mình.
Nên các em cần coi hiểu rõ và cái phần
này á,
nếu mà các em phân biệt rõ và các em nắm
thông tin và ở đây các em đi làm rồi.
Phải là các em sẽ có kinh nghiệm nhiều
hơn một có phiền,
một vài khía cạnh bên đây thì các em có
kinh nghiệm nhiều hơn với các bạn chính
quy thì các em nên phân tích và nắm cái
này rõ để cái mình tự kiểm soát cái nội
dung của mình ha.
Tại vì mình nắm rõ cái này thì các em.
Phân tích về các cái tính cách thiết tính
mới và đưa ra quy trình phạm vi đối tượng
phạm vi thực hiện của mình,
nó sẽ chính xác hơn tại vì em có tiếp xúc
bên ngoài,
có tiếp xúc với nhiều vụ thiệt rồi.
Còn cái này thì các bạn sinh viên có thể
là kỹ thuật và lý thuyết là các bạn mạnh,
nhưng mà cái nghiệp vụ thì thường các bạn
hơi yếu nên ở đây khi mà cô hướng dẫn thì
cô cũng biết được điểm mạnh,
điểm yếu ở từng nhóm sinh viên khác nhau.
Nhưng mà biết nghiệp vụ thì mình phải dạy
cho đúng.
Cái thứ 2 là các ứng dụng web và một bài
desktop thì đây là mấy cái ứng dụng mà
người dùng phải tương tác kiểu là mình
tương tác mình tiếp xúc thôi theo suốt
hiện tại thì mọi người hay đi theo web
mobile nhiều.
Còn.
Sau đó là các cái thành phần kiểu Mrowa
và số vịt để phục vụ.
Mình làm cái này là chi tiết cho các buổi
lát và các slide tiếp theo.
Cũng sẽ nói giống như cái nick giao tiếp
vậy đó và hệ điều hành và phần cứng.
Tự nhiên mình phải có hệ thống phần cứng
theo phân phát phù hợp thì mình mới có
thể triển khai trong phần mềm.
Ở đây cũng nhắc lại,
tại vì khi mà các em phát triển truyền
thống phần mềm thì mình phải suy nghĩ coi
cái hệ thống phần mềm,
cái môi trường trại của mình có.
Phù hợp và hay không và có tích hợp được
khai đóng phần cứng hay không?
Rồi mình giờ mình đi vào từng loại thì
thường là ở đây các em sẽ nghe tới hệ
điều hành là cái lớp trung gian giữa phần
cứng và phần mềm.
Nó sẽ cung cấp môi trường chặn.
Mạng và quản trị tài nguyên cho cả 2 nhóm
đối tượng chính là người dùng ứng dụng và
thiết bị phần cứng thì đối với các chuyên
ngành của mình thì cái này là mình mình
biết thôi.
Còn nếu mà trước đây vào thời nó chưa có
phân rõ công nghệ thông tin đâu thành
nhiều đáng rõ.
Thì nếu học trong ngành công nghệ thông
tin thì các em sẽ học lập trình tổ học
trình.
Trên cái ngôn ngữ phần cứng,
cái này nó sẽ.
Ngôn ngữ phần lập trình trên hệ thống
phần mềm mà ngôn ngữ cấp cao là ngôn ngữ
gần với ngôn ngữ con người.
Còn cái ngôn ngữ lập trình trên phần cứng
lập trình nhúng thì nó sẽ có cái quy tắc
lập trình hơi khác nhau.
Còn cái này thì bên.
Bây giờ thì tách ra rồi nên ai mà học
chuyên giống như ngành kỹ thuật máy tính
thì mình mới học tới cái bên phần cái
ngôn ngữ lập trình trên phần cứng thì
nhiều hơn.
Còn đối với cái hệ thống phần mềm thì
mình tiếp xúc nhiều hơn về cái phần mềm
như là cái hệ thống hệ điều hành này các
cái.
Trừ các chức năng,
chương trình hỗ trợ kem backup antay
Antivaruss, Virus, rồi Beast Schools,
rồi mấy cái agent.
Thì mục tiêu của cái phần mềm hệ thống
này nó sẽ giúp duy trì vận hành ổn định
và cung cấp dịch vụ.
Làm cho cái hệ thống của mình.
Thường thì mấy cái phần mềm này nó là
những cái phần mềm đầu tiên khi mà các em
thời xưa,
thời xưa Kovo rất tốt thì phải cài cái
này nhiều hơn.
Còn thời gian gần đây thì cái này bạn nào
mà không được cài thì lúc mình mua máy nó
ra được hỗ trợ cài sẵn rồi hết.
Nhưng mà nếu mà cài thì theo trình tự là
mình sẽ phải xây dựng,
phát triển hệ thống phần mềm hệ thống.
Đối với cái phạm vi doanh nghiệp thì các
em sẽ cũng sẽ xây dựng thôi.
Thường thì cái này là mình sử dụng của
cái hệ phần hệ thống và mình mua.
Bản quyền thì trong cái hạ tầng đầu tư
của em á.
Em cần phải xác định cái hệ danh sách cái
hệ thống phần mềm hệ thống mà các em cần
phải cài đặt.
Để mình dự toán cái số lượng iPhone mình
phải mua và trả phí.
Theo thời gian để mình dự toán được kinh
phí đầu tư và kinh phí kinh phí vận hành
cho cái dự án bên đồ án và đồ án của mình
hả em? Cái này bên đồ án,
còn bên bà Thịnh hành thì nó chỉ là phát
triển hệ thống phần mềm ứng dụng cụ thể
thôi.
Còn trong cái dự án đầu tư thì cái dự án
phần phát triển hệ thống vấn mềm thì cái
này không quan trọng.
Nó không có làm trong phạm vi,
nhưng mà nếu mà dự án phát triển đầu tư
và vận hành thì các em cần phải chú ý tới
cái loại danh sách này.
Để mình đưa ra cái dự toán đầu tư phù hợp.
Rồi tiếp theo là cái phần mềm ứng dụng
thì cái phần mềm ứng dụng thì nó sẽ phục
vụ cho nhu cầu của người dùng của đơn vị.
Thường thì kem cái có một số các ứng dụng
phần mềm ứng dụng văn phòng,
nó có sẵn và mình cũng sẽ gần giống như
trên đây là phần mình phải đóng lên đây
là các em sẽ khi mà các em đưa ra kế
hoạch đầu tư á thì mình tính toán tới cái
lison sang cho nó phù hợp.
Với cái nhu cầu của người dùng của mình,
xác định chi phí đầu tư và chi phí vận
hành mua bản quyền ha.
Còn đối với các cái ứng dụng mà nghiệp vụ
như thế này hoặc là các web Mobile app.
Thì thường là theo cái nghiệp vụ riêng ở
một cơ quan thì cái này,
nếu mà các công ty cơ quan đầu tư mà
người ta có cái quy trình nghiệp vụ riêng
biệt thì sẽ thường phải thêm một đội kỹ
thuật để chuyên làm cái.
Cái phần mềm theo nghiệp vụ và theo nhu
cầu của dùng thì cái này là cái khi nếu
mà mình trong team phát triển hệ thống
phần mềm,
cái này nó giống như cái bài thực hành
của các em á là các em muốn xây dựng cái
hệ thống phần mềm phục vụ trong việc cụ
thể.
Mình sẽ phải đi tìm hiểu về cái nghiệp vụ
đó,
đi phỏng xác định nhóm người dùng rồi làm
việc,
đi hiểu về cái quy trình làm việc ở công
ty của những nhóm người dùng cụ thể chúng
ta người đã làm cái gì,
có thể có những buổi phỏng vấn nhỏ để
hoặc là thông qua hợp đồng để mình biết
cái.
Gọi chức năng mà người ta yêu cầu xong là
dựa trên kinh nghiệm của mình,
hoặc là dựa trên các cái hệ thống tương
tự để mình bắt đầu thiết kế thiết kế xây
dựng.
Bạn nào mở mic vậy?
Rồi thì sẽ đi theo thiết kế thì cái bài
bài thực hành của các em vùng lớn là cái
em sẽ xây dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm
nghiệp vụ.
Thì cái này trong giai đoạn đầu á thì cái
hệ thống phần quyền nghiệp vụ nó có nhiệm
vụ là hỗ trợ quản lý các thông tin quan
trọng.
Trong cái nghiệp vụ đó và giúp cho cái
người dùng tương tác với có chức năng
giúp người dùng tương tác và cập nhật các
thông tin quan trọng trong nghiệp vụ,
trong quy trình hoạt động của nghiệp vụ.
Để người ta quản lý sức báo cáo và kiểm
soát vận hành ha,
nhưng mà đến thời điểm hiện tại thì xu
hướng là người ta muốn xây dựng các hệ
thống phần mềm hỗ trợ nghiệp vụ thông
minh hơn.
Nó sẽ không dừng ở cái mức độ quản lý mà
nó có thể dừng ở mức,
nó có thể cung cấp cái chức năng ứng dụng
trí tuệ nhân đạo dự đoán sớm,
hoặc là xây dựng,
hoặc là đưa ra cái khuyến nghị.
Thì cái này các em sẽ thấy khá là nhiều,
ví dụ,
giống như một trang thương mại điện tử
thì nó sẽ gồm có cái quy trình,
các cái quy trình của người bán,
người mua của bên bên đơn vị giao vận,
là các quy trình hoạt động trên sàn á.
Thì nếu mà một nghiệp vụ mà ở cấp độ quản
lý có nghĩa là mình chỉ cần quản lý được
hết tất cả các thông tin và đảm bảo tất
cả các hoạt động,
nó đều được quản lý và có chức năng đầy
đủ cho tất cả các nhóm người dùng,
từ người mua,
người bán đến bên giao vận chẳng hạn bên
em xuất khách hàng.
Thì nếu mà cái xây dựng cái hệ thống sàn
mà kiểu phần mềm theo cái nghiệp vụ cơ
bản như vậy thì ta gọi là cái phần mềm
nghiệp vụ theo kiểu quản lý.
Nhưng mà em thấy hiện đại là trong các
nghiệp vụ bên sàn thì nó sẽ có các cái
chức năng.
Nhìn vào được em thấy nó là có ứng dụng
AI,
cái điển hình mà mình quen nhất đó chính
là cái hệ thống khuyến nghị của hệ thống
khuyến nghị,
hệ thống khuyến nghị trên các sàn thương
mại điện tử thì nó sẽ chạy theo nhóm
người dùng, có nghĩa là tùy theo lịch sử.
Mua hàng,
sở thích mua hàng hoặc là của em trên sàn,
hoặc là nó là nguồn dữ liệu trên sàn để
gợi ý cho các em. Cách đây khoảng 50 năm,
10 năm về trước thì các sàn điện tử hoạt
động theo kiểu đó.
Nên các em sẽ thấy một cái tình bạn nào.
vụ hẹn cho xe của mạng điện tử vào thời
điểm đó thì sẽ thấy nếu mà mình search
cái gì trên sàn thương mại điện tử hoặc
em đã mua cái gì trên sàn thương mại điện
tử thì cái lúc mà em đăng nhập vào thì em
sẽ thấy là tất cả các cái sản phẩm quảng
cáo đó sẽ theo em.
Sẽ dẫn theo em,
nhưng mà nó sẽ do cái dữ liệu của nó chỉ
là dữ liệu trên sàn nên nó dẫn đến một
cái tình trạng là đôi khi em search cái
sản phẩm đó.
Sau đó em mua cái sản phẩm đó rồi và em
không còn nhu cầu mua nữa.
Nhưng nó vẫn tiếp tục quảng cáo.
Ví dụ,
giống như trước đây cô mua một cái laptop
trên sàn thì mua xong rồi nó vẫn cứ quảng
cáo thôi. Cách đây khoảng mười mấy năm,
á là nó vẫn cứ quảng cáo miết thôi.
Tại vì nó không có dữ liệu mới nhưng mà
sau này thì.
Người ta cái hệ thống khuyến nghị ứng
dụng trí thời gian tạo thông minh thì nó
có dữ liệu nhiều hơn,
ví dụ nó lấy dữ liệu trên cái trang công
cụ tìm kiếm Google hoặc là trên trang
mạng xã hội của các em nên đôi khi những
cái gì em tìm kiếm hoặc cái gì mà em xem.
Các sản phẩm mới nào đó thì lúc mà em qua
sàn thì em thấy quảng cáo sản phẩm nó
cũng theo em luôn thì kỳ vọng đó là nó
lấy cái thông tin chính xác hơn thông qua
các hoạt động.
Kỹ thuật số trên mạng của mình.
Và nó thể hiện được cái nhu cầu tại thời
điểm hiện tại thì mình sẽ thấy cái.
Hệ thống khuyến nghị nó thông minh hơn
một chút.
Thông minh hơn một chút,
mặc dù mình cảm giác nó hơi bị nó hơi bị
nó theo dõi chút xíu,
nhưng mà là nó xác nhận chính xác cái nhu
cầu buôn bán của mình.
Mua sắm của mình cao hơn,
có nghĩa là thông minh hơn đối với cái hệ
thống quý vị trước đây.
Thì cái xây dựng cái hệ thống phục vụ hỗ
trợ nghiệp vụ và có ứng dụng công nghệ
mới ở đây là cái phần hệ thống khuyến
nghị đó thì cái chức năng hệ thống khuyến
nghị mà được tích hợp vào sàn bên cạnh
các nghiệp vụ quản lý cơ.
Khoảng thì người ta gọi là cái đó là cái
xu hướng của cái phát triển cái hệ thống
phần mềm ứng dụng hiện tại,
ha cái đó là một cái ví dụ nên các em có
thể ví dụ các em cái công ty các em chọn
sàn thương mại điện tử đi.
Và trong cái sàn đó thì nó có cái chức
năng cơ bản,
nhưng mà em thấy là nó chưa đáp ứng được
nhu cầu người dùng của em.
Kỳ vọng là xây dựng tích hợp,
nâng cấp cái hệ thống đó lên để cho hệ
thống thông minh hơn,
tăng trải nghiệm người dùng hơn.
Chẳng hạn.
Thì các em có thể viết cách thức về đề
tài phát triển hệ thống phần mềm với chức
năng quản lý cơ bản,
bên cạnh đó là có cái chức năng thông
minh ứng dụng AI,
ứng dụng khai thác dữ liệu lớn chẳng hạn.
Để xây dựng cho các cái.
Chức năng thông minh hỗ trợ cho người
dùng theo các hướng cá nhân hóa.
Cái xu hướng hiện tại là vậy,
hoặc là ví dụ giống như bệnh viện chẳng
hạn,
bệnh viện thì hiện tại là mình mới có
dừng ở cái việc là.
Xây dựng bệnh án điện tử cho bệnh nhân là
mình sẽ lấy được các cái thông tin của
bệnh nhân.
Tích hợp tất cả kết quả xét nghiệm của
bệnh nhân tại cái bệnh viện đó để hỗ trợ
cho bác sĩ khám chữa bệnh tốt hơn,
nhưng mà một cái số hiện tại mà là nhiều
cái dự án bên y khoa đang làm và đặt hàng
rất là nhiều.
Mặc dù nó chưa triển khai nhưng mà cấp độ
nghiên cứu và.
Đang nghiên cứu cơ bản thì nó làm khá là
nhiều đang chạy khá là nhiều.
Đó là cố gắng xử lý các loại dữ liệu y
khoa khác nhau thì có nhiều nhóm nghiên
cứu sẽ đi theo cái dữ liệu y khoa như là
dữ liệu ảnh X quang hoặc ảnh CT.
Để làm bài toán phân lớp hoặc là bài toán
Sherpintation,
bài toán xác định khối u hoặc xác định
cái thành phần bất thường trên ảnh CT
hoặc ảnh XY thường đó là sẽ là phân ảnh
khối u á hiện phát hiện của u á.
Để hỗ trợ bác sĩ đọc cái bệnh án nhanh
hơn và chính xác hơn,
hoặc là làm bài toán phân lớp này giống
như dựa trên các kết quả xét nghiệm lâm
sàng để mình dự đoán các khả năng bệnh
giống như sự thiếu hụt vitamin D.
Hoặc là có khả năng bị một cái bệnh hiếm
nào đó dựa trên các kết quả xét nghiệm
hiện tại ta gọi là giữ trên các chỉ số
bất thường để dự đoán bệnh á thì sẽ hỗ
trợ cho bác sĩ đưa ra cái liệu trình.
Khám chữa bệnh chuyên khoa hơn,
chuyên khoa hơn và có thể đưa ra cái lộ
trình khám chữa bệnh và tầm soát bệnh.
Thí dụ mình có nghi ngờ mình bị ung thư
thì dựa trên các chỉ số này mình có thể
mình chưa làm.
Cái các xét nghiệm chuyên khoa về ung thư
nhưng mà dựa trên các cái xét nghiệm kết
quả khám sức khỏe chẳng vậy để mình dự
đoán các cái bệnh nguy cơ nguy cơ bệnh
khác để mình.
Tăng cái khả năng chữa trị dành cho bệnh
nhân thì nó thường là đang có 2 cái xu
hướng đó và đương nhiên là bệnh y khoa
thì nó có rất là nhiều loại ảnh,
thí dụ không phải chỉ ảnh hưởng quang CT
rồi nó còn có ảnh điện tâm đồ,
dữ liệu điện tâm đồ.
Dữ liệu gen dữ liệu sinh thiết gen vân
vân thì các nghiên cứu cơ bản hiện tại là
đang làm riêng biệt với mọi loại dữ liệu
và đương nhiên là cách lúc nào nó cũng sẽ
có cái giai đoạn nghiên cứu cơ bản và đến
khi nào mà nó ổn định rồi thì có thể tích
hợp ứng dụng.
Thử,
nhưng mà là cái đó là cái xu hướng chung,
cái xu hướng chung và vẫn có thể dừng ở
mức demo nhưng đương nhiên là nó có thể
không thành thay thế cho bác sĩ được mà
nó chỉ hỗ trợ bác sĩ đạt kết quả tốt hơn,
hoặc là hỗ trợ bác sĩ dự đoán.
Trong những trường hợp mà bác sĩ chưa có
nắm vững thông tin,
ngoài ra thì bên yêu khoa nó còn có một
cái bài toán lớn đang làm đó là.
Nó có hay có những hình như trong nhóm
của các em có một lớp mình có một bài
nhóm thì liên quan về dữ liệu truyền
thông chia truyền dữ liệu á,
nhưng mà là ở đây thì nó không có ở cấp
độ truyền nữa á, ở cấp độ chia sẻ dữ liệu.
Thì làm sao chia sẻ dữ liệu.
Y khoa Y khoa một cách an toàn tại vì
lượng dữ liệu y khoa hiện tại ở các bệnh
viện làm mạnh bệnh viện nào sẽ bệnh viện
đó quản lý và không chia sẻ thông tin
được.
Nhưng mà với nghiên cứu thì người ta cũng
nói rõ ràng nếu mà các bệnh viện.
Chia sẻ dữ liệu y khoa được cho nhau á nó
giống như một số nước nó có thể làm rồi á
là mình sẽ có một cơ sở dữ liệu y khoa
chung dành cho cả nước.
Hình như bên Sing là làm được rồi,
bên Sing là được rồi,
có nghĩa là có một cơ sở dữ liệu về chia
sẻ y khoa an toàn giữa tất cả các cơ quan
y,
các bệnh viện hoặc là các cơ sở y tế khác
nhau.
Và thì khi đó là nó sẽ giải quyết được
vấn đề là những cái xét nghiệm nào mình
đã làm rồi thì mình không phải xét nghiệm
lại và cái thứ hai là mình nhìn được lịch
sử và án của bệnh nhân tốt từ có thể từ
thời điểm mà bệnh nhân đó sinh ra cho đến
thời điểm hiện tại.
Thì mấy cái thông tin đó là bây giờ
nghiệp hiện tại đối với các bác sĩ thì
mình còn nó còn khó có thể là mình phải
dựa trên các cái kết quả xét nghiệm mà do
bệnh nhân cung cấp hoặc là do trao đổi
bệnh nhân biết chứ bác sĩ khó khó khó
không?
Có thông tin đầy đủ,
nhưng nếu mà cơ sở dữ liệu mình chia sẻ
và quản lý được kiểu đó thì nó sẽ hỗ trợ
cho bác sĩ khám chữa bệnh tốt hơn.
Tại vì bên lĩnh vực y khoa thì nó sẽ có
một yếu tố là bệnh di truyền.
Và mình cần phải có sự khoa của những
người thân nữa, và tiền sử bệnh án,
tiền sử bệnh án mà bây giờ mình đi hỏi
bệnh nhân thì nó cũng hên xui,
hên xui không phải bệnh nhân nào cũng nhớ
là hỏi cung cấp thông tin một cách đầy đủ.
Nhưng mà nếu có thể chia sẻ thì nó sẽ
giải quyết được cái vấn đề đó rất là
nhiều,
nhưng mà nó có một cái vấn đề là làm sao
để cho các cái bệnh mắc bệnh cơ sở y khoa
các bệnh viện.
Có thể tin tưởng được kết quả xét nghiệm
của nhau và khi mà chia sẻ không bị làm
rồi thông tin của bệnh nhân thì hiện tại
là nó cũng là một bài toán khá là hay.
Nên nếu mà mình ví dụ mình cái bài thực
hành của.
Ở của các em là cô cho để các em học để
làm,
có cơ hội để các em làm quen với một cái
biết về một nghiệp vụ và các cái vấn đề
của nghiệp vụ đó thì và cái xu hướng hiện
tại là người ta đang muốn phát triển ứng
dụng công nghệ mới để nâng cao các tích.
Nên quản lý bình thường các chức năng
thông minh hơn, cá nhân hóa tốt hơn,
an toàn hơn,
bảo mật hơn nên cái bài thực hành là các
em có thể phát triển theo xu hướng đó và
ở đây là các em chỉ cần tìm hiểu về các
nghiệp, các cái công nghệ mới.
Và cái công nghệ đó là gì?
Và mình có hiểu về cách mà nếu mà mình
phát triển thì nó có thể xây dựng được
một cái hệ thống thông minh hơn và an
toàn hơn, chẳng hạn.
Rồi cái em chỉ cần nắm được các các kỹ
thuật làm ý tưởng làm.
Và cái dự kiến chi phí để mình viết một
cái thuyết minh và thực hành là được thì
cái thuyết minh mà thực hành này cô sẽ
chống theo cái mức độ em hiểu công nghệ
đến mức độ nào thì dụ em chỉ dừng là em
biết cái vấn đề và có công nghệ ứng dụng.
Hay là em sẽ hiểu rõ về các bài vấn đề đó
và các bài toán đặt ra cho vấn đề đó là
gì?
Các kỹ thuật chi tiết và các bước triển
khai một cách đầy đủ để có thể giải quyết
cái bài toán đó và sử dụng các công cụ
công nghệ nào dựa trên nền tảng nào.
Mặc dù em không triển khai nhưng mà em
biết cách sử dụng,
em biết cách là em biết cách em biết cách
là cần có công cụ cần có công nghệ còn có
kỹ thuật cần có phương pháp đó để làm thì
nếu mà nếu nào đạt được tới mức đó thì sẽ
đỉnh cao hơn.
Được.
Thì đó là cái nói về cái phần mềm ứng
dụng,
tiếp theo là nói về cái lớp kết nối điều
phối hay là cô nói thì cái này nó là một
cái cung cấp năng lực dùng chung để giúp
mình kết hợp, tích hợp,
điều phối và sự quan sát và sử dụng chung.
Cái ứng dụng trong cái hệ thống lớn.
Ngoài ra thì các cái số việc bên cạnh cái
việc dùng chung thì nó còn có các chương
trình chạy nền cung cấp chức năng thông
qua cái network.
Và nó có một số cái đặc điểm để cho mình
hỗ trợ các cái.
Lưu,
đặc điểm để mà hỗ trợ và kiểm tra thì
thường đây là những cái dữ liệu quan
trọng đó,
kia ở đây mình người dùng thì mình ít
quan tâm dữ liệu về bọt endpoint hoặc là
có health chế hay không,
rồi block cấu hình ra sao,
rồi cái lịch sử truy cập về truy cập rồi.
SLI nội bộ như thế nào?
Nhưng mà đối với các dữ liệu này dùng hỗ
trợ cho quá trình trong lĩnh vực detox
cien để hỗ trợ để các em xây dựng các
phần mềm thông minh hơn và an toàn hơn
thì.
Cái là dữ liệu này thường xuyên dùng ha ở.
Và cái tư duy hiện tại thì người ta đang
cố gắng lại các cái chức năng hệ thống
của mình giống như một cái dịch vụ để
người dùng dễ sử dụng hơn.
Rồi tiếp theo là khái niệm ảo hóa,
khái niệm ảo hóa này là.
Cái em nghe một cách dân dã là em nghe
theo từ nghe từ máy ảo. Cái em viết,
có bạn nào dùng không biết có dùng máy ảo
chưa ha?
Thì cái máy ảo của mình á là nó sẽ chạy
trong một phần cứng thật và nó thường là
nó giống như phòng ritorsinter của trường
mình.
Có cái hệ thống máy chủ đã được ảo hóa để
cho nhiều nhóm kiếm,
nhóm nghiên cứu vô từng để tự quản lý và
trả thực nghiệm riêng thì cái lợi ích của
nó là cách ly mạnh,
tận dụng tài nguyên và dễ cái Snapshot và
backup.
Nhưng mà tốn tài nguyên hơn là cái
container và cái đồng trọng hơn.
Cái này nó sẽ nhưng mà các cái mình chia
sẻ dữ liệu mã hóa thì nó mang tính chất
độc lập và an toàn hơn.
Còn hành thanhner thì nó cái nó giống như
một khái niệm em đóng gói ứng dụng và
mình chia sẻ cái container một cái host.
Lợi ích của nó là nhẹ, khỏi đồng nhanh,
triển khai đồng nhất.
Nhưng mà hạn chế là cách ly nước thường
mỏng hơn và.
Hai giữa hai cái này thì tùy theo cái nhu
cầu sử dụng thôi.
Ở ví dụ giống như nhu cầu sử dụng của các
nhóm nghiên cứu ở trong trường và cho
thực nghiệm là muốn cái tính độc lập tại
mỗi nhóm theo nghiên cứu ở một lĩnh vực
riêng á.
Thì thường sử dụng cái lựa chọn phương
thức ảo hóa này nhiều hơn thì khi mà các
em đưa lên dự án đầu tư và phát triển hệ
thống phần mềm cho doanh nghiệp mà các em
đang chọn cái này tùy theo cái ngữ cảnh,
cái này ra thì các em đưa ra giải thích
và sự lựa chọn của.
Rồi tiếp theo,
á khi mà các em đưa ra cái dự án đầu tư
có thể là em mua livestream hoặc là em tự
phát triển thì các em còn đều phải quản
lý vòng đời phần mềm để đảm bảo cho nó ổn
định, an toàn và tuân thủ. Có kế hoạch.
Để phát triển các phiên bản triển khai
vận hành giám sát,
cập nhật phá lõi và kết thúc vòng đời
hoặc là thay thế bằng cái phần mềm phù
hợp hơn.
Và ngoài ra thì mình còn phải quan tâm là
cái hệ thống nó nó có.
Tương thích là phụ thuộc lẫn nhau hay
không?
Tại vì cái hệ thống phần mềm của mình,
nếu mà các em chỉ chạm một cái thì nó đơn
giản nhưng mà nếu mà hệ thống xây dựng
cho một cái doanh nghiệp thì nó sẽ còn có
rất là nhiều hệ thống với nhau thì khi mà
các em đưa ra danh sách đội.
Một tư về các hệ thống phần mềm ứng dụng
và phần mềm hệ thống và phần mềm ứng dụng
mình điều kiện triển khai á thì các em
cần phải kiểm coi về cái thông tin cấu
hình và đảm bảo nó có tương thích và hỗ
trợ kiểm soát nhau tốt.
Chứ không nó, nó không tương thích,
có nghĩa là các cái gói phần mềm mà nó
complit với nhau.
Ở tiếng Việt hay có thể gọi là mâu thuẫn
với nhau mà nó không hợp nhau thì cái làm
cho có thể làm cho hệ thống mình bị lỗi
ha?
Và khi mà các em cảm kiểm soát cái đó tốt
rồi thì mình mới giảm về rủi ro pháp lý.
Ở đây chắc mình nghe trước đây thì không
cái này không mạnh nhưng mà thời gian gần
đây thì em nghe rất là nhiều nha.
Nếu có mấy cái tất cả các cái.
Phần mềm mình đưa ra thì phải là phần mềm
có bản quyền và mình phải có lãi sinh,
có cái kế hoạch phát triển đầu tư cho một
doanh nghiệp phù hợp chứ không là nó sẽ
có rủi ro pháp lý và hiện tại là phạt rất
là nặng về vụ này ha. Và khi mà mình.
Nói cái này đương nhiên phải kiểm toán và
chi phí phát sinh.
Để mình có thể có cái giấy phép đầy đủ,
có hình thức quản trị và trong cái gói
chi phí đầu tư mà người ta đưa ra cho
mình.
Hồi đó là cái những cái nội dung quan
trọng cho cái hệ thống phần mềm ở đây,
các em có chỗ nào không rõ luôn.
Nếu không có chỗ nào không rõ thì bây giờ
cô hướng dẫn bài thực hành với bài đồ án,
rồi mình giao bài tập về làm từ từ cho em.
Rồi cái phần bài đọc ngày hôm nay là cô
đã giao rồi,
2 bài tập lập kế hoạch giai đoạn 1.
Nhóm trưởng đại diện nhóm hay nhóm trưởng
thư ký hoặc là một bạn đại diện nào cũng
được nhớ đọc bài trước nha các em các em
tạo một founder bài tập lập kế hoạch cho
đoạn một.
Và ở đây mình sẽ lập kế hoạch giai đoạn
một cho cả tuần đồ án và bài thực hành.
Bà thực hành thư đầu tiên mình nói về đồ
án trước cái đồ án thì bữa trước mình đồ
án với bà thực hành hôm trước á là mình
đã có cái ở cái mức không khảo sát và lên
ý tưởng cơ bản đối với bà thực hành rồi
thì coi đương nhiên là có nhóm có thông
tin đầy đủ, còn với nhóm màu vàng.
Thì bác Hồi có kem có chỗ nào chưa rõ
hoặc là có nhóm nào cập nhật đề tài á tin
đề tài thì báo cô thì để cô cập nhật lại.
Rồi bây giờ mình nói về đồ án môn học nha
em thì các em vào đây.
Mình vô cái phần hướng dẫn đồ án môn học
hôm trước là mình đã chọn được cái công
ty mình muốn làm,
xác định được cái phạm vi đề xuất cơ bản.
Cô nhắc lại là ở đây là mình lựa chọn ở
cái giai đoạn đầu,
nhưng mà thí dụ trong cái quá trình mình
triển khai có mình có thể hiệu chỉnh cái
phạm vi đề xuất sao cho phù hợp với mình.
Trước khi các em viết thành một cái bảng
báo cáo hoàn chỉnh.
Cái này phải lên thực tế đối với cái dự
án thuyết minh á nó cũng sẽ thay đổi
giống như một vòng của một cái đề tài cấp
đại học quốc gia hoặc cấp bộ thì nó cũng
sẽ trải qua vài vòng kiểm tra từ thẩm
định từ hồ sơ.
Thẩm định chuyên môn rồi tới thẩm định
tài chính thì nếu mà đầu nhưng mà có thêm
quy định mới là nó sẽ thông qua vòng của.
Hội động khoa học trường có nghĩa là các
trường thành viên phải chịu trách nhiệm
về cái đề tài của mình khi đăng ký cho
đại học quốc gia.
Nên khi mà đưa lên cái ý tưởng ban đầu
giống như xác định cái phạm vi đề xuất
ban đầu và thường nó là một cái bản.
Ngắn nhất nước dưới trang dưới trang là
từ 10 trang đổ lại,
miêu tả ngắn gọn và cái nhiệm vụ,
cộng nhiệm vụ hoặc chủ nhiệm vụ của mình
thì hội đồng khoa học sẽ đánh giá cái ý
tưởng của mình.
Đồng thời sẽ đánh giá cái.
Năng lực của nhóm nghiên cứu đăng ký tại
vì cái này thực hành viên là cái hiểu rõ
về nhân lực của mình trước thì sẽ đánh
giá cái nhóm này nó có khả năng làm đề
tài nữa hay không.
Rồi cái đề tài này nó có ngoài ra là do
cái đề tài ở các trường thành viên thì nó
sẽ thuộc nhiều ngành khác nhau,
không phải chỉ có ngành công nghệ thông
tin mà cũng có các ngành kinh tế, luật.
Các ngành về bên vật lý sinh học hay là
bên của đại học sức khỏe hay là của các
cái ngành liên quan về bên xã hội nhân
văn thì nó sẽ có rất là nhiều ngành khác
nhau nên cái thường cái đến.
Bỏ đại học quốc gia cũng sẽ có các hội
đồng cho các ngành chuyên biệt,
nhưng mà nó sẽ khó đạt,
khó nó khó chuyên sâu hơn so với các cái
trường thành viên tự mình kiểm dịch ban
đầu nên thường đạt trường.
Nhiệm vụ của hội đồng khoa học của trường
là mình trường khoa học,
khoa học của trường thì chắc chắn là sẽ
có chuyên gia chuyên môn về các lĩnh vực
ở trường mình đang giảng dạy.
Thì sẽ trải qua hội đồng khoa học của
trường.
Góp ý trước.
Góp ý rồi mình sửa,
sửa xong rồi mới viết thành một cái bảng
hoàn chỉnh rồi lên đại học quốc gia thì
bắt đầu mới kiểm định hồ sơ rồi bắt đầu
mới lên vòng một vòng kiểm định chuyên
môn của đại học quốc gia mà qua được 2
dòng kiểm định chuyên môn thì sẽ mới tới
cái dòng kiểm định tài chính.
Thì khi qua mỗi cái vòng như vậy là sẽ có
cái nhận xét và mình sẽ có cái chỉnh sửa
ban đầu nên nó sẽ chỉnh sửa nhiều vòng
giống như ở đây.
Cô cho các em báo cáo họ các em làm cho
các em báo cáo tiến trình.
Rồi cô góp ý và các.
Em trao đổi trong quá trình mà các em làm
thì các em sẽ hiệu chỉnh từ từ nên trong
các nội dung mà bữa trước mình làm ở đây
một trang ở trong phần setup producer thì
nó có thể là gọi là ý tưởng ban đầu của
mình thôi,
có thể là tới giai đoạn một này sau 3 các
cước em làm em.
Có sự hiệu chỉnh lại phù hợp và điều
chỉnh được hết nha các em.
Chứ mình không có nhất là khắt khe đi
theo cái đó,
mình làm sao mình chọn lựa chọn phù hợp,
nhưng mà tới cái buổi báo cáo tuần cưới
cuối hoặc là cái bộ sữa cuối rồi thì mình
nên chốt để có thời gian để mình hoàn
thiện.
Thôi chứ mỗi cứ mỗi lần các em nổi là các
em sẽ thay đổi hết là một tất cả các nội
dung đi kèm nó tốn thời gian lắm.
Rồi bữa trước là mình bài nói là mình có
xác định phạm vi đề xuất rồi thì bây giờ
nội dung của cái bài tập này thì đây đối
với đồ án thì mình sẽ làm từ bước 1 đến
mức 4 nha các em.
Bước 1 của mình là các em sẽ khảo sát cái
hiện trạng hạ tầng có số liệu,
mục tiêu là thuyết phục bằng dữ liệu,
không phải bằng cảm tính giống như ở đây
mình có 5 lớp chức năng thì mình sẽ thu
thập theo 5 lớp từ tính toán.
Nói of security and that ứng dụng thích
hợp và dữ liệu à và cái các chỉ số em nên
có cái vụ các chỉ số này đây là các cái
chỉ số đo lường và đánh giá hiện trạng.
Trạng của cái hạ tầng mà mình đang làm.
Thì cái này bữa trước cô có cho các em.
Làm cái cô cũng có nói là mục tiêu của
mình là để mình học và nghiên cứu chứ cô
không có yêu cầu em thanh tra nên nếu mà
thí dụ cái công ty đó các em chọn mà các
em có thông tin và các em biết hiện trạng
thực tế của công ty.
Thông qua các nguồn tài lực khác nhau thì
các em có thể miêu tả chí tiết trong đây
còn không hoặc là hoặc là còn không mình
không có hoặc là do cái dữ liệu của em
mang tính chất bảo mật cao mà nó không
phù hợp để ở đây dữ liệu thật.
Ở đây á thì các em phải chọn giả lập bữa
trước của nó là các em sẽ tiến hành giả
lập á.
Nếu trong trường hợp các em không có
thông tin chính xác hoặc là các em có
thông tin nhưng dữ liệu đó là dữ liệu mật
nên mình không thể nào để thông tin.
Sử dụng thông tin trong bài tập của mình
thì chọn cái phương án thứ 2 ha là mình
sẽ tiến hành giả lập cái hiện trạng hiện
tại của cái cơ quan ở đó.
Với ở đây thì các em thông qua chỉ số gia
lập và các em sẽ giả lập các hiện trạng
và các cái benboy là những cái vấn đề
hoặc cái số liệu mà nó chưa đạt,
và bây giờ mình cần cải tiến trong quá
trình đầu tư phát triển.
Những loại cái hạ tầng cơ sở thông tin.
Anh nói lại kem hình dung.
Là dựa trên cái tài liệu ở cái mức không
và các nguồn tài liệu và cái,
và cái phạm vi mà các em muốn làm thì các
em sẽ giả lập về cái hiện trạng của các
lớp hoặc của các thành phần mà các em dự
kiến đầu tư.
Trong bài đồ ăn của mình thì các em có 2
hướng,
nếu có những sự thật mà nó không có ảnh
hưởng gì về quyền quản mật.
Thì có thể sử dụng và làm nguồn thí dụ
trước đây có một số nhóm các bạn chọn các
công ty mà nó có.
Dữ liệu thật và nó có công bố dữ liệu tài
chính,
chị thì các bạn sinh viên lúc đó các bạn
không có đi làm nhiều nên các bạn chọn
mấy công ty mà có trên trang web đó,
người ta có công bố báo cáo tài chính
hoặc là báo cáo tài dự kiến phát triển
trong.
Doanh thu trong 5 năm tiếp theo thì các
bạn dựa trên mấy nguồn đó để các bạn tiến
hành giả lập cái hiện trạng hạ tầng ở đây.
Ha sau đó rồi.
Các bạn dựa trên cái nền tảng đó thì các
bạn đặt ra vấn đề đều các bạn tiến hành
đầu tư phát triển, nâng cấp. Ở đây,
các em cũng có thể.
Nếu có thông tin mà nó không vấn đề gì
thì dùng thông tin thật còn không thì
mình tiến hành giả lập.
Nếu mà không có thông tin hoặc là thông
tin nó mang tính chất bảo mật,
nhắc lại nha các em.
Rồi ở đây một số chỉ số.
Linh có tối thiểu tối thiểu ha.
Như là cái SLI of Cam hiện tại là cái số
sự cố trong vòng 3 đến 6 tháng,
tỷ lệ backup thành công,
rồi tỷ lệ thiết bị, rồi tỷ lệ lỗ hổng,
rồi.
Tăng trưởng của người dùng trong từ 12
đến 24 tháng ra sao? Đây là tối thiểu và.
Chắc là nó có nhiều thông số chỉ số thôi,
các em chỉ số đo lường,
các em có thể tự mình tìm thêm các chỉ số
đo lường.
Nhưng nhớ đến link tới tài liệu thuận ảo
gốc nha.
Tài liệu tham khảo gốc là các tài liệu đã
được.
Viết bởi chuyên gia được kiểm chứng,
có ban biên tập rõ ràng.
Ví dụ như là các sách,
các bài báo đã được công bố,
lá được công bố,
hội nghị hoặc tạp chí hoặc là các cái tài
nguyên học tập ở các trường được cung cấp
là có chuyên môn đảm bảo cho nội dung đó.
Thì mình mới sai tới là mình là mình mới
trích dẫn tới nó là mình trích dẫn tới nó
đó,
còn mấy cái nguồn mà chỉ do internet và
người ta up lên và mình không biết tác
giả hoặc là tác giả đó mình cũng không
biết là cái độ uy tín của tác giả.
À,
người ta nói cái điều đó là người ta có
chuyên môn về vấn đề đó hay không á thì
không nên dùng cho các em vì.
Giờ ai cũng nói được,
nhưng quan trọng người đó có chuyên môn,
lời người đó rất có đáng tin hay không
thì trong cái lĩnh vực mà viết báo cáo
này thì người ta xét cái đó rất là cách
nha kim.
Nên mấy cái chỉ số đo lường này thường là
nó đã được chứng minh và nó được công bố
toán học,
công bố rõ ràng rồi thì mình nên dùng thì
có thể dùng,
không có tự tham khảo các chỉ số trên
mạng.
Mà chưa được kiểm chứng.
Rồi đó là cái bước 1.
Còn cái bước 2 là tiếp theo là sau khi em
giả lập được cái hiện trạng rồi em giả sử,
em nói là cái số sự cố,
cái hiện tại trong 3 đến 6 tháng ở công
ty đó nó cao cho nên.
Giống như trong từ 3 đến 6 tháng có tới
100 sự cố đã diễn ra.
Rồi cái tỷ lệ backup hiện tại backup
thành công là nó dưới 50% chẳng hạn,
rồi tồn tại nhiều lỗ hổng chưa vá và số
lượng tăng trưởng người dùng đang tăng
rất là nhanh.
3 4 lần trong vòng 12 tháng chẳng hạn.
Thí dụ em đưa ra một số cái giả lập về
cái hiện trạng đang có thì bắt đầu khi có
cái thông số giả lập rõ ràng rồi thì dựa
vào đó cái em sẽ tiến hành nêu vấn đề và
rủi ro không đầu tư.
Để mình chuyển từ đề nghị mua sang rủi ro
và tăng năng lực.
Thí dụ mình thường có thể viết theo 3 cụm
ha cái này cô gợi ý thôi.
Ở đây các em có thể viết theo từng khác
nhau là tác động vào quá trình vận hành
nè, tác động và tuân thủ và an ninh,
tác động vào chiến lược phát triển.
Của công ty đó là nếu mà cái hiện trạng
này để các vị chỉ số này nó đang nêu ra,
nó là cái hiện trạng thì nó nêu ra các
vấn đề về gì và giống như là nhãn hiệu
năng, mất dữ liệu.
Có khả năng rò rỉ thông tin,
hoặc là bắt các thành công như rò rỉ
thông tin hoặc không đáp ứng nhu cầu làm
cho thông tin.
Vậy thông tin không được an toàn và bị
mất chẳng hạn.
Rồi cái tốc độ tăng trưởng cao mà với cái
nhu cầu hiện tại của mình á thì chiến
lược của mình nó không mở rộng được theo
chi nhánh kênh và tích hợp chậm vân vân
thì ra đây các em sẽ nêu ra các vấn đề.
Và nếu mình sẽ thường thường đi vấn đề ở
đây thì các em hãy viết theo cái phong
cách, cái phong cách chung thôi.
Nếu chuyện đó xảy ra.
Thì nó sẽ có ảnh hưởng như thế nào?
Gây ra thiệt hại bao nhiêu?
Để người ta thấy là ra cái tính cách
thiết của việc mà phải sự kiện cái dự án
này.
Thì cháu uống này,
cái an ninh trình bày này lúc đó thì các
em sẽ giết cái mức cấp thiết rất là hay
ha.
Rồi mình có thể đưa ra nếu mình,
nếu mà người ta đầu tư cái vấn đề này thì
giải quyết về vấn đề trên chi phí đầu tư
là bao nhiêu,
nhưng mà giảm thiệt hại là bao nhiêu?
Nếu chi phí đầu tư thấp nhưng mà giảm
thiệt hại lớn chẳng hạn thì người ta sẽ
thấy cái đề tài này.
Cái dự án này khả thi.
Tiềm năng sau đó là các em xác lập các
cái mục tiêu và KPI hạ tầng ở đây là
giống như là các cái mục tiêu.
Nó giống như các lời hứa của các em về dự
án,
kem hứa là em sẽ xây dựng dự án có các
chức năng gì, các chức năng đó tốt ra sao.
Cái này là trong cái đề cư khối lượng của
các bạn sinh viên,
các bạn cũng hay hứa nhiều lắm á.
Mọi người kem có thấy khá là nhiều bạn
hứa rất nhiều,
nhưng cuối cùng là các bạn làm không được
bao nhiêu á nên thường cái này là sẽ có
giáo viên hướng dẫn kiểm tra mức độ phù
hợp và sẽ đăng ký lên đề phương lên khoa
thì khoa cũng sẽ kiểm tra một vòng để yêu
cầu chỉnh sửa sao cho.
Nó phù hợp và thường cái mà các bạn thiếu
là các bạn hứa,
nhưng mà các bạn không có cái số liệu rõ
ràng.
Không có cây bị ai chuẩn để cần đo lường,
thí dụ các bạn hứa là các bạn sẽ có chức
năng và tăng độ chính xác và tăng độ
chính xác dự đoán và tăng hiệu quả hoạt
động của mô hình.
Thì nó rất là chung chung với em.
Nó không có đo lường được.
Và đối với các dự án thuyết minh đề tài,
người ta cũng không thể nào sử dụng dựa
trên cái nào đó.
Tại vì cái đó nó chính là cái tiêu chí để
người ta lập hợp đồng thanh toán và
nghiệm thu thanh lý cái đề tài sau này.
Nên cái mục tiêu và cái KPI của mình,
nó phải rõ ràng,
có lẽ là người ta sẽ có mục tiêu miêu tả
bằng lời sao đó là mình sẽ đưa ra cái KPA
rõ ràng giống như mình nói là tăng hiệu
quả hoạt động của model.
Ví dụ như độ đo ki proxy resent recon sẽ
tăng.
Chẳng hạn là mình phải nói ra một cái số
con số và có cái chỉ số đo lường rõ ràng
ha.
Thì nếu mà đối với các đề tài lớn mà KPI
ở các cơ quan lớn thì thường người ta sẽ
có bảng KPI riêng là người ta đã nghiên
cứu và lập ra một cái bản KPI quy định
riêng.
Thì thường mình chỉ dựa vào cái bảng KPI
đó mình đánh thôi.
Thí dụ người ta là đặt á sẵn,
người ta có phân.
Và các loại sản phẩm đúng không thì mình
và mức giá chi phí để người ta sẽ trả cho
từng loại sản phẩm đó thì mình nói mình
đăng ký ca một thì với một ca một thì có
thể trả từ 300 đến 400 triệu cho một cái
sản phẩm ca một chẳng hạn.
Thì nếu mà mình làm cho dự án của công ty
người ta có camera sẵn rồi thì mình chọn
theo km của chúng ta thôi.
Có thể là cái quy định riêng người ta đưa
đã được đưa quyết định rõ ràng thì mình
cứ đi theo quyết định của cơ quan đó để
mình làm MA thôi. Còn trong trường hợp.
Người ta không có cây me rõ ràng thì mình
sẽ phải sử dụng các giá trị camera chuyên
môn.
Như mấy cái chỉ số KPI ở đây cô có gợi ý
sẵn nè.
Là cái ca vay chuyên môn cho mình chuyên
môn để mình đặt ra cái lời hứa của người
ta cho người ta có thể thấy rõ ràng ha
chứ không là sẽ không là hợp đồng mà sau
này nghiệm thu cũng không biết là như vậy
là đạt hay chưa hay không đạt á nó không
rõ ràng.
Tiếp theo là tới cái bước 4 là xây dựng
phương án kiến trúc tovi.
Là ở đây là mình sẽ có.
3 kịch bản, 3 kịch bản này bữa trước,
cô có gợi ý cho các em về cái 3 kịch bản
thì ở đây thường mình sẽ chuẩn bị cả 3
kịch bản,
rồi với mọi kịch bản mình sẽ miêu tả kiến
trúc điểm, tích hợp và khả năng mở rộng.
Và sau đó là mình nên có so sánh và chốt
cái kịch bản phù hợp luôn.
Đây phần lớn các bạn sinh viên trước đây
là các bạn làm cả ba.
Nhưng mà làm ra cả 3 xong rồi các bạn
cũng không biết nên làm cái nào.
Mình là chuyên gia xây dựng ở đây thì
mình phải có sự so sánh và đưa ra cái dự
án cụ thể, dự án cụ thể mình làm cái gì.
Nó vừa hãy và bắt đầu mình có thể chi
tiết hơn đối với cái dự án lựa chọn tiềm
năng nhất thì đó là cái 4 mức rồi cái
phải đổi môn học.
Ngày kem xa làm tiếp theo.
Chỗ này các em có cho nó không rõ không?
Nhất là mấy cái nhóm màu vàng này đây,
nhóm 1 nè, nhóm 1.
Cái này các em nắm thông tin để biết cách
làm cho em.
Nếu mà có ai đi học không?
Nhóm của bạn Sơn nè.
Dạ, nhóm đem ngắm rồi cô.
Ừ
Cô chơi xem là cái danh sách dấu của.
Tìm kiếm gia tài không?
Cái này là trên tàu điện vô học,
các em có thể tự lên kiểm tra được các em.
Vô đây nè.
Được cái.
Linh tài liệu môn học xong rồi vô danh
sách lớp rồi mở cái xe lên coi được nha
các em.
Rồi nếu mà cái đó ổn rồi thì bây giờ.
Bữa trước mình có bước không rồi,
có nhóm chưa đã rõ thông tin và có nhóm
chưa rõ mà có thêm một tuần thì con nghĩ
sao góp ý thì các em đã xác định rõ hơn
rồi, tại bây giờ mình làm tiếp.
Từ bước 1 cho đến bước 4 hả em?
Bước bộ với bước 4.
Đâu có bài tập theo bài tập lên.
Từng bước 1 đến bước 4 á em.
Từ kiến làm.
Rồi tiếp theo là mình nói về bài thực
hành.
Và thực hành thì nó nhẹ hơn nó nhẹ về
phạm vi nhưng mà nó nặng về kia công nghệ
mới.
Bài thực hành ở đây của mình là mình sẽ
xây dựng cái chứng minh đề tài xây dựng
một cái phần mềm cho doanh nghiệp ứng
dụng công nghệ mới đúng không?
Thì cái bước không bên đây của mình nó là.
Chuẩn bị cho đầu vào như là mình phải mục
tiêu của mình cũng là gom đủ thông tin
thuyết minh như để đúng vấn đề,
đúng phạm vi,
đúng chi phí và đúng hiệu quả thì thường
các cái nội dung mà mình cần thu thập như
là bối cảnh doanh nghiệp nè.
Vấn đề hiện tại đối tượng sử dụng hệ
thống liên quan và các ràng buộc ngân
sách cái này nó gần giống như cái bài
thực hành rồi cái bài đồ án của các em.
Và đồ án của các em.
Mới trước cái bài đồ án, các em chốt rồi.
Bữa trước là các bà xác định và My đề
xuất là các em cũng có cái thông tin cơ
bản và về công ty đó rồi,
các em về công ty, các vấn đề quy mô,
phần thu hoạt động cơ cấu tổ chức,
các quy trình hoạt động.
Thì các em chọn.
Nếu mà mình muốn chọn tốt nhất á thì kem
theo cái phạm vi mà các em chọn cái đồ án
thì các em lấy cái phạm vi đó,
các phạm vi trong phạm vi đó thì các quy
trình nào có thể phát và xây dựng các hệ
thống phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới.
Nhiều cái phạm vi mà em chọn được thì
cũng được luôn còn không á là mình có thể
chọn bất kỳ một cái quy trình nào ở đây.
Hồi nãy lúc đưa cô nói phụ thuộc cái phần
mềm thì phụ thuộc vào người dùng.
Và quy trình hoạt động.
Quy trình nghĩa vụ á thì các em có thể
chọn bất kỳ cái quy trình nghiệp vụ nào ở
nhưng mà nó vẫn phải ở công ty của các em
chọn ha cái này cô không có giới hạn ngày
xưa thì cô có bắt làm bài thực hành với
bài đồ án cũng cần sự liên kết với nhau
nhưng ở đây để cho các em dễ phát triển.
Chuyển hơn thì cô giới hạn và mi rộng hơn
là các em có thể chọn bất kỳ cái quy
trình nghiệp vụ nào ở công ty mà các em
đăng ký đồ án đều được hết và các em dựa
trên đó,
các em cũng đã có bối cảnh rồi đúng không?
Có vấn đề.
Đối tượng sử dụng hệ thống các hệ thống
nào liên quan và các ràng buộc phân sách
thời gian tuân thủ để các em chuẩn bị các
cơ sở để các em bắt đầu viết hệ thuyết
minh xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm của các
em.
Cái này là 2 cái này khá là dùng khá
chung nữa,
em bên đây với bên đây dùng chung nó nâng
cái bước không thì cô tái sử dụng lại.
Chỉ có nhắc lại phạm vi làm,
các em có thể chọn bất kỳ một cái quy
trình nghiệp vụ nào.
Không nhất thiết là cái quy trình nghiệp
vụ mà có liên quan tới cái bài đồ án của
mình, không nhất thiết.
Xong rồi, cái tiếp theo thì bắt đầu làm.
Mình sẽ viết cái đặt cái tên cách đặt tên
đề tài một cái thông tin chung ở đây là
các em chưa có làm thì các em có đặt tên
một cái đề tài để các em xác định cái
phạm vi ban đầu của cái dự án phần mềm
của mình. Thường là sẽ bắt đầu từ động từ.
Cái đối tượng em muốn làm phạm vi và cái
bối cảnh,
ví dụ em muốn như đây là xây dựng hệ
thống quản lý đơn hàng tồn kho đa kênh.
Cho doanh nghiệp bán lẻ.
Thì các thông tin chung như đơn vị chủ
trì,
đơn vị phối hợp chủ nhiệm thời gian và
địa điểm triển khai thì các em có thể dự
kiến ở đây và.
Ở đây là các em có thể tiến giống như cái
phạm vi của bài đồ án,
nếu mà các em không có thông tin hoặc
thông tin nó mang tính chất bảo mật thì
các em có thể giả lập cái vấn đề về quy
trình nghiệp vụ,
quy trình nghiệp vụ mà công ty của em
đang chọn cái.
Đang gặp phải và các em sẽ xây dựng cái
hệ thống phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới
để giải quyết vấn đề trên.
Nói chung đặt tên thì nó không có cái quy
định rõ ràng,
gợi ý cho cái có nhiều thì có nhiều cách
đặt tên lắm.
Đặt tên nhưng mà ngày làm sao mà đặt tên
vô á là người ta biết em đang làm cái gì,
biết em áp dụng công nghệ mới nào.
Ở đây cái phần này nó mới vừa ở dừng ở
cái góc độ doanh nghiệp,
nhưng mà nếu mà đối với những cái dự án
phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới thì
thường người ta sẽ thêm cái tên,
công nghệ mới vô cái tên đề tài luôn là
cộng thêm tên công nghệ mới nhưng cái này
nó bắt buộc hết.
Nhưng mà nếu mà trong thời gian đây qua
thì cô gợi ý là em người ta đang có xu
hướng là người ta cần biết em giải quyết
nghiệp vụ gì và ứng dụng công nghệ mới
nào.
Nên thường trong cái tên công nghệ vô
luôn.
Giống như ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo của
dự án ghi chữ ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo,
ứng dụng khai thác dữ liệu lớn, vân vân.
Cái này là do mình đặt tên,
tạm thời để mình xác định phạm vi.
Xong rồi tới cái bước 2 của mình là bối
cảnh lý do.
Chọn đề tài thì nó sẽ gần giống như bên
đây luôn.
Sau khi khảo sát hiện trạng thì em biết
vấn đề rủi ro không đầu tư thì cái này nó
cũng gần giống như vậy.
Mục tiêu của mình là mình sẽ cho người ta
biết là cái quy trình nghiệp vụ ở đây thì
phạm vi nó nhỏ hơn cái quy trình nghiệp
vụ của người ta.
Hiện tại người ta đang làm,
đang có hiện trạng như thế nào.
Và nó đang có hiện trạng như thế nào nè,
và tiếp theo là cái vấn đề điểm đau có
nghĩa là nếu theo cái hiện trạng đó thì
nó đang có cái vấn đề nào còn tồn tại và.
Nếu mà mình không xử lý thì nó sẽ.
Gây ra hậu quả gì?
Còn nếu mà mình đầu tư vô hệ thống phần
mềm này thì nó có thể giải quyết được các
vấn đề trên như thế nào và tiết kiệm,
đem lại ích gì cho doanh nghiệp.
Những cái ý tưởng cũng gần giống như nhau
để dựa.
Trên cái bối cảnh,
cái hiện trạng đang có vấn đề đang có để
làm cái cơ sở để xây dựng cái hệ thống
phần mềm.
Dự án của mình.
Thì ngồi mình nếu mình biết theo bối cảnh
đó thì người ta đang thể hiện về tính cấp
thiết của đề tài ha.
Rồi mục tiêu cây với tiêu chí thành công
thì cũng giống như bên đây thôi hả em?
Ở đây là cái mục tiêu của em và của cả hệ
thống đầu tư.
Còn ở đây là chỉ về nói về các phần mềm
thôi, chức năng,
phần mềm mà em hứa với người ta là em sẽ
làm như thế nào.
Và có cây BA rõ ràng.
Rồi cái đối tượng phạm vi và giả định và
ràng buộc.
Ở đây anh hỏi khác đối tượng phạm vi của
mình thì nó.
Nó giống như cái.
Một phần của cái bước xuất thông của
người phía trước á bước xong và cái giả
định về cái khảo sát hiện trạng bước 1
của mình á.
Thì cái bên đây nó còn giống hơn bên đó à
là cái em tổng hợp là đối tượng phạm vi
là cái khảo sát hiện trạng mà người ta có
mà bây giờ em sẽ chọn em làm cho nhóm đối
tượng đó thôi và em dự kiến là em sẽ
triển khai cái phần mềm này trong phạm vi
nào là nó có các cái.
Ở thường có thể là cái phạm vi đó,
em có thể nêu hình danh bixin chức năng
em hứa là em làm với người ta hoặc là các
chức năng sẽ được xây dựng cho một cái
quy trình nghiệp vụ cụ thể nào đó,
hoặc là xây dựng cho toàn bộ quy trình
nghiệp vụ nào đó.
Vừa ví dụ quy trình nghiệp vụ là khám
chữa bệnh tại bệnh viện chẳng hạn.
Cái em sẽ phải xác định cái phạm vi đó
rồi các em,
các cái giả định ràng buộc nó giống như
cái phần hiện trạng hạ tầng đã phát hiện
trạng bên đây nè.
Là em có cái kết.
Cái hiện trạng của công ty,
cái vấn đề của quy trình nghiệp vụ đó rồi
thì các em sẽ tiến hành giả định những
cái hạ tầng ngân sách tham gia và tiêu
chuẩn bảo mật dân sự của doanh nghiệp sẽ
tham gia giống người dùng sẽ tham gia vào
cái hệ thống công việc của mình.
Để mình đưa ra các gia đình và ràng mục.
Còn nếu mà mình làm thực tế thì cái này
người ta sẽ cho mình ha.
Ví dụ người ta nói tôi có các loại đề tài
nè, ngân sách nhiêu đây nè,
dự kiến thời gian quy định.
Thí dụ đối với Đại học Quốc gia thì thời
gian đề tài thường thường sẽ là từ 1 năm
đến 2 năm.
Đối với các đề tài lớn,
cần nhiệm vụ chủ nhiệm vụ xa,
hoạt động từ 3 đến 5 năm và người ta sẽ
có cái mốc tham gia và tiêu chuẩn rõ ràng
luôn.
Thì mình đọc kỹ quy định rồi mình viết
theo cái tiêu chuẩn của người ta.
Còn nếu mà trong trường hợp hồi nãy tôi
nói, nếu mà không có.
Có đưa ra cái quy định tiêu chuẩn rõ ràng
là doanh nghiệp và cơ quan nó không có
cái họ không có tiêu chuẩn riêng của họ
thì là mình thường sử dụng các tiêu chuẩn
chuyên môn để mình đưa ra viết cam kết và
viết mấy cái giai đoạn ràng buộc này.
Là đối với các bạn đối với các bài thực
hành.
Rồi các em, nhóm đây,
nhóm thông tin không các em,
nó chỗ nào không rõ luôn.
Nhưng mà 8.
Chứng tán về những bữa trước mà.
Dạ dạ dạ rõ ạ.
Rồi nếu mà không có vấn đề gì thì bây giờ
cô giáo ngoài tập về nhà,
ha các em nhớ nha em coi cái này.
Hồi nãy giờ coi nhóm nào là bà chưa mới
có 2 nhóm học bài ha.
Beadline trong ngày hôm nay thôi nên các
em cô ta deadline để tránh để dài,
các em sẽ quên cái tại cái này Ngọc Linh
right thôi mà.
Các em còn sau đó các em sẽ làm việc trên
right nên cô tạo cái thời gian và cái
thời điểm thông báo để các em nhớ người
đó.
Nhóm.
Nay mình có bao nhóm, một nhóm,
một nhóm là đại diện 11 nhóm, nhớ đọc bài,
tạo cái folder bài tập,
lập kế hoạch chế động 1.
Xong rồi các em đại diện.
Nhóm của mình học bài như hướng dẫn,
sau đó kem phân công ra các bước tiếp
theo của đồ án môn học và thực hành để
mình tiến hành triển khai và thực hiện
nha.
Rồi cũng quên nhắc lại.
Buổi học tiếp theo của mình.
Một cái thông báo đây,
cô đây mất tiêu rồi.
Cái con tạo cô vô đây, quý học tiếp theo,
mai cô nhớ cô bố lên rồi mà ta cho nó đau
rồi.
À đây nè.
Buổi học tuần sau cái buổi học tiếp theo
của mình trúng cái thời gian nghỉ lễ hay
tháng 9 nên mình sẽ được nghỉ và là tập
bù của mình là ngày 3 tháng 9 đó các em.
Những bạn nào mà bị trùng lịch thì kem có
thể xem video,
nhưng mà cố gắng sắp xếp là buổi sáng của
mình là buổi báo cáo tiến trình,
báo cáo tiến trình về cái nội dung bài
tập này mình làm nè.
Nên phải có đại diện nhóm tham gia để
trao đổi và lấy cái thông tin về để mình
tiến hành thực hiện tiếp cho nhóm của
mình như cái em.
Rồi nếu không có vấn đề gì nữa thì buổi
học của mình sẽ cúp qua đây sao em?
Dạ, cô ơi.
Dạ em là đại diện của nhóm chính đúng
không?
Em có thể nhờ cô kiểm tra lại giúp em
nhóm em bức không được không ạ?
Lĩnh chính này phải.
Dạ đúng rồi.
Ở những của mình là gì,
công ty cổ phần phát hành sách pha xa
không?
Dạ.
Cái nào kem.
Và cơ sở hạ tầng công nghiệp thông tin
bài tập chương 3.
Làm cái bài tập sách từng phòng với đề
xuất đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi.
Là cái nào?
Dạ cái có cái file tên là cơ sở hạ tầng
công nghệ thông tin và tập trung 3 ấy cô.
Cái này hả, đúng rồi sáng.
Ở trên ở trên tay mục lục của cô.
Và cái này không?
Dạ đúng rồi
Sáng nay cô nói luôn,
các nhóm bữa trước cô chấm bài,
Dạ.
cô cũng bị tình trạng này nè. Các em làm,
các em có thể chia công việc của nhau và
các em làm rất là nhiều file.
Thì mấy cái phần mà đó các em tạo một
founder như là referent hoặc là.
Cái fonder tài nguyên resort vậy của các
em đều được.
Và các em phải có một cái file nằm ở quân
ngoài cùng và cái file phái nô báo cáo mà
của mình nó để các em dễ để cô dễ chấm
bài kiếm các em đợt trước là cô cũng bị
tình trạng như này nè xong rồi cô phải
đón coi file nào là file chính và cô chấm
thôi.
Các bạn đặt tên tùm lum hết á.
Và để nhóm em sửa lại phần này.
Có rất là nhiều phiên bản luôn.
Đúng rồi và các bạn có nhiều phiên bản có
và lúc đó cô phải vừa cùng là bài báo cáo
bài tập này này cô phải nhìn cái thêm
thời gian cái này cũ nhất cô lấy á.
Cô cũng không biết đó phải là cái bài
chính xác của các em không,
nhưng mà các em làm vậy thì nếu nó không
đúng bài đó thì mình là do lỗi mình quản
lý fonder nó không hợp nha.
Rồi bây giờ là cái scope,
một trang của kem để ở đâu?
Dạ,
cô bấm bên cái cột bên trái là nó ra cô.
Có project có hả cô?
Còn bên trái là ngọt ngào.
Cho nó có cái phần project up là một mục
riêng luôn á cô.
Cái này á hả?
Này Phương.
Dạ.
Ủa, cái này nó cũng nhiều trang mà em.
Còn gì như này là cái gì?
Ở dưới là ý tưởng phần mềm và thực hành.
Ok.
Đầu tư nền tảng ứng dụng tích hợp và nền
tảng dữ liệu cho hệ thống bán lẻ.
Phần
Mềm của ác, phần cứng,
phần mềm của đây ta phát rơm.
Là 3 thành 33 thành phần trong bảng xạ
đúng không anh?
Dạ đúng rồi.
Đâu cũng được đấy, chi tiết rõ ràng hơn.
Dạ em cảm ơn ạ.
Rồi với giọng nha các em chứ của em để về
cô vuốt cô chấm bài điểm quá trình của
các em là dựa trên các cái báo cáo của
mấy cái bài tập mà cô giao á nha các em.
Nên làm sao mà vô là cô biết cô đau cái
file gì để cô chấm nha.
Dạ để em sửa liền ạ.
Dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi Dũng sao em.
Dạ, nhóm 1 em có thay đổi đề tài đó cô.
À, đổi đề tài ứng.
Em có đăng lên cái bốt rồi.
Là cái này đúng không em?
Dạ dạ đúng rồi cô.
Dạ quên cô xem giúp em cái cái bài làm
chúng em.
Em vỡ từ em có sửa lại trên nóc.
Ở đây,
nhóm của mình nếu mà các em chọn 2 lớp
năng lực mình đầu tư rồi.
Thì cái này là tới nay phạm vi ở đây là
ổn rồi,
còn vì sao mà mình chọn 2 lớp năng lực
này thì em nên đưa ra lý do vì sao mình
chọn nó chứ em đừng nên đừng nên đừng
cánh trình bày theo kiểu là lý do vì sao
tôi không chọn mấy cái.
kìa.
Tại vì thực chất lớp nào,
lớp nào nó cũng sẽ có cái ý tưởng và
Cả cái.
người ta chỉ cần, và cái này,
cái xu hướng chung của cái xu hướng khi
đánh giá chung của các đề tài,
người ta chỉ muốn biết là tại sao tôi
phải đầu tư lớp năng lực này nếu mà không.
Đầu tư thì đem lại hậu quả gì và nếu đầu
tư thì sẽ được em hai cái lớp,
cái dự án của các anh chị sẽ đem và lớp
cho tôi là cái gì,
là cái nhóm đối tượng mình chọn là cái
lớp 2, lớp 3 này đem lại ích gì,
rồi mình đứng thẳng vô thôi. Chứ.
Không có mình tránh trình bày theo kiểu
ngược là do lớp 1, lớp 4, lớp 5.
Nó không quan trọng bằng lớp 2,
lớp 3 nên tôi trình bày lớp 2, lớp 3.
Thì cái đó nó giống như là cái cách mà em
đưa ra sự lựa chọn,
nhưng mà cái mà khách hàng hoặc là cái.
Bên hội đồng đánh giá người ta muốn biết
là tại vì thực chất là cái nào nó cũng sẽ
có cái ưu điểm,
có cái đem lại lợi ích riêng,
lớp nào nó cũng có năng lực cơ bản hết.
Đến cái việc của em nói là bây giờ cái
bên lớp bên đây nó không quan trọng bằng
lớp bên đây nên tôi đánh giá vào lớp bên
đây á.
Nếu mà các em trình bày thì kiểu đó mình
rất là dễ bị bẻ nha các em gọi là dễ bị
bẻ chừng lắm luôn á.
Tại vì ngay cả trong ví dụ trong các cuộc
họp mà em nghe.
Vấn người ta tranh luận về vấn đề là cái
nào quan trọng hơn cái nào hết.
Là nó sẽ tùy theo những góc nhìn,
tùy theo góc nhìn của cái người đó và cái
quan điểm của người đó nữa nên mình đừng
có viết theo kiểu mà tạo ra sẽ có khả
năng tạo ra tranh cãi.
Mà hãy viết theo trọng tâm vấn đề,
giờ tôi làm nhóm 2, nhóm 3.
Và nếu mà làm thì nó đem lại lợi ích gì
không làm thì đem lại lợi ích,
không lợi ích gì và người ta sẽ người ta
sẽ.
Lúc đó người ta sẽ tập trung vào cái lớp
năng lực mẹ muốn đầu tư luôn chứ mình
không có lo lớp lực khác vô rồi sẽ tạo ra
các cái.
Tranh luận và sửa phạm vi đề tài.
Tại vì ở đây,
nếu mà người ta nói có người người ta
không thích hoặc là cái quan niệm người
ta không thích.
Tôi nói nhóm lực số 1 nó vẫn tốt mà.
Nếu mà em tạo cái này thì em sẽ rất là dễ
bị hội đồng sửa cái phòng vi đề tài của
mình.
Nếu mình không muốn.
Ở bên hội đồng tạo đựng tạo điều kiện cho
hội đồng hay là tạo sự lựa chọn cho hội
đồng để hội đồng sửa cái phần viên đề tài
của mình tại mà nếu mà phạm vi đề tài của
mình làm thì các em tưởng tượng là em đã
viết qua dòng thuyết minh rồi,
cái bản thuyết minh của em đã hoàn thiện
để em ngựa kiểm định rồi thì lỗi nhỏ.
Thì nó sao nha,
nhưng mà nếu mà cái lỗi mà sắp sửa phạm
vi đề tài á thì không phải mình chỉ sửa
một chỗ cái chỗ phạm vi đề tài,
phạm vi đề tài thay đổi thì mục tiêu thay
đổi nội dung thực hiện thay đổi và phương
pháp thực hiện cũng sẽ thay đổi theo.
Hình như cái câu nói giống 1.
Nên nếu mà các em đã làm chọn nhóm 2,
nhóm 3 thì mình nói thẳng vào nhóm 2,
nhóm 3 thôi.
Đừng đưa ra option khác để cho người ta
xử của mình.
Với lại so sánh cái này nó không có,
nó mang tính chất quan điểm lắm.
Thì cái đó là rất yếu cô,
ví dụ ở đây là tới đây là học rồi thì
mình nói, nói thẳng vô tại sao tôi phải,
tại sao tôi làm cái này giống như là viết
được,
viết một cái đề tài hoặc là đưa ra một
cái nghiên cứu cho hỏi tại sao bạn làm
bài toán này?
Thì mình nói đúng như bài toán đó thôi
chứ mình không đi so sánh các bài toán
khác do cái bài toán bên kia hiện tại nó
chưa có tốt lắm nên tôi làm bài toán này
mình mình nói câu đó là cái người,
cái nhóm nghiên cứu nào mình đang làm cái
bài toán kia hoặc là người ta theo hướng
nghiên cứu kia á.
Là người ta ý kiến với mình liền luôn á
nên cái nguyên tắc là không có so sánh
cái bài toán hay là các nhóm năng lực với
nhau.
Làm ở đâu thì mình nói thẳng mình làm đó
thôi.
Ủa mà sao cái này nói 1 trang mà cuối
cùng là viết quá trời vậy?
Nguyên cái này là cũng trang của các em á
hả?
Dưới ngắn gọn thôi hả em?
Phần mềm, phần cứng và hạ tầng.
Cái này là cái cột, các em.
Dịch vụ đi kèm đấy chị.
Thành phần dự kiến đầu tư của các em là
các em nhìn vô bản tham chiếu nha,
nhìn bản tham chiếu ở chương 2 á.
Mô hình 5 lớp.
Rồi những coi lại thành phần dự kiến đi
ha, có thể là phần mềm, phần cứng,
còn cái dịch vụ đi kèm là không có cái
trong phạm vi nha.
Mấy cái này nó không phải là cái dịch vụ
đi kèm hoặc là thành phần cơ sở hạ tầng
em.
Cái này là cam kết về khi mà em làm dự án,
em bắt buộc phải cho người ta thôi.
Em làm xong rồi em phải chuyển giao,
em phải có hướng dẫn nhân sự training
trên nhân sự chứ nó bắt buộc mà.
Công nghệ mới có thể áp dụng.
Rồi mới áp dụng này, công nghệ của cái gì,
các em muốn vô cái gì, vô thành phần nào.
Và chủ yếu là phần mềm mới cung.
Nếu mà vô cái này,
nếu mà các em muốn gọi là cải tiến cho nó
thì các em cần phải nói rõ,
ví dụ với 2 lớp năng lực này và với cái
thành phần nào các em đang làm,
dự cho bản ánh xạ và em định đầu tư tìm
hiểu các công nghệ.
Trong từng thành phần đó thì các em nên
theo nó,
còn cái danh sách nhóm công nghệ mà
chuyên về phần mềm á mà nó nói chung
chung quá trong việc nằm trong cái phần
dự án hạ tầng đầu tư ban đầu mà nó chưa
rõ đó.
Thì nó sẽ dễ bị hoang mang lắm nha các em.
Tại vì cái thành phần này đây là đầu tư
dự án thì nó phần lớn là em sẽ có đầu tư.
Thí dụ có phần cứng thì em phải mua thiết
bị mới,
rồi có mua lại xanh và các cái kế hoạch
mua lái xanh của các phần mềm.
Nền tảng khác,
còn các phường bị ứng dụng nào là các em
sẽ dự kiến triển khai thì các em có thể
nêu vô các phần mềm ứng dụng dự kiến
triển khai.
Cơ bản.
Và cái công nghệ mới mình có áp dụng là
nó có thể làm ở bất kỳ thành phần nào chứ
nó không phải chỉ ở phần mềm.
Còn nếu mà em nói em muốn áp dụng công
nghệ mới cho hệ thống phần mềm thì em qua
làm bài thực hành.
Rồi mình diễn giả chi tiết nó ra thì chỉ
nên chọn 1 thôi.
Các em phải hiểu dân công nghệ của mình,
cái kiểu, cái trong ngành khi mà anh làm,
người ta biết sự phức tạp khi một làm áp
dụng công nghệ mới.
Nên một cái bạn công nghệ hoặc là một cái
thuyết minh thường là người ta chỉ nói về
một nhánh công nghệ mới sẽ được áp dụng
thôi.
Trừ khi em làm giống như nãy cô nói là
chuỗi nhiệm vụ hoặc là cụm nhiệm vụ từ 3
đến 5 năm.
Cái dự án nó dài vậy đó và nó cao nhiều
nhóm tham gia với nhau thì mới có cái
chuyện là áp dụng nhiều bài toán khác
nhau và nhiều cái hướng công nghệ mới
khác nhau.
Còn nếu mà một cái dự án mà mình làm
trong vòng 1 đến 2 năm á.
Thường thường là chỉ một nhánh công nghệ
là đủ mệt rồi chứ không có làm nhiều được
đâu cái em.
Thì nói chung là cũng tùy theo cái lực
lượng tham gia nhân lực mà đủ thì có thể
làm,
nhưng mà nếu mà em làm nhiều thì em phải
hiểu rõ về các công nghệ này,
em trình bày thì nó mới có ý nghĩa.
Còn việc mà em chỉ nêu tên mà em không
hiểu nó là cái gì á.
Thì cô điểm đó cũng không đánh giá cao
đâu nha,
kêu giống như hồi nãy bà thực hành.
Cô có nói với em á,
cô đánh giá mức độ các em hiểu chi tiết
về nó là em có thật sự hiểu về nó hay
không.
Biết cách triển khai và cách vận hành của
nó.
Còn cái việc mà đưa tin công nghệ rồi nói
chung chung á AI giờ làm nhiều mà nó đâu
có ý nghĩa gì.
Giờ nói xa cái mấy cái đó xinoray dễ.
Thì cô không có chấm đánh giá cao mấy cái
đó đâu ha.
Rồi đó là cái mấy cái góp ý nhóm hiệu
chỉnh lại.
Cảm ơn cô.
Rồi mẫn đạt sao.
Nhóm bạn nào xong rồi tắt giơ tay hết.
Người này không trả lời pha.
Dạ anh ạ, nhạc cô cô ơi, cô anh em nói mà.
Nửa đêm.
Dạ, cô ơi, cho cô,
cho em hỏi cái về cái vấn đề mà nhóm em
đang tiếp cận,
nhóm em đang tiếp cận theo hướng là
resort cái phần mà doanh nghiệp đó cô.
Là resort.
Em muốn làm đang hỏi về đồ án hay thực
hành.
Dạ về cái thực hành á.
Là heo theo như quy trình của em nghe thì
tụi em sẽ giả lập một cái quy trình cụ
thể, sau đó tụi em sẽ áp dụng,
áp dụng vào một cái công nghệ ngay tại vì
một cái quy trình đó đúng không cô?
Còn cái đồ án thì mình sẽ làm theo hướng
là phân tích,
phân tích yêu cầu và thu hợp dữ liệu đúng
không cô để mình đưa ra các nhu cầu,
ví dụ như là tài liệu này còn làm các quy
trình này còn làm một cái gì.
Và mục tiêu đầu cuối và KPI rồi này kia
hơi đúng không cô?
Không em.
sao
Bài đồ án thì mình nên coi cái phần đồ án
cho kỹ về cái phần hướng dẫn thực hiện đồ
án ở đây.
Mục tiêu của mình là mình đưa ra một cái
đề xuất dự án đầu tư cơ sở hạ tầng cho
doanh nghiệp.
Còn bây giờ em chỉ là khảo sát xác định
phạm vi đưa ra đầu cuối thì nó làm sao
người ta biết là em muốn đầu tư dự án và
phát triển cụ thể như thế nào.
Chứ nếu mà cái của em làm và các em mới
làm tới mức không thôi đó.
Ý là của.
Và và và một vài cái bước một,
đây là bài đồ án.
Các em hình dung phương đồ án ở đây là
nếu mà làm tiếp thì các em có thể đọc
tiếp đến cây giống như chuẩn hóa yêu cầu
kỹ thuật nè, lập danh mục hạ tầng đầu tư,
dự toán chi phí phân tích tài chính,
kế hoạch triển khai theo từng giai đoạn,
quản trị rủi ro.
Tạo thay đổi và đảm bảo chất lượng rồi
cách thức tổ chức dự án,
cơ chế phối hợp giữa các thành phần khi
mà các em đầu tư với giả sử giống như có
bên nhóm FASA nãy á là các bạn tròn đầu
tư hai lớp năng lực đó.
Rồi phương án dự mua sắm,
chọn nhà thầu và các em phải dự toán kinh
phí và các em có đưa ra các em khảo sát
có giá trị thị trường của các nhà thầu và
các thành phần mà em dự kiến làm bạn em
dự toán chi phí giá.
Giả sử giống như em nói em pha xa bằng
các bạn đầu tư 2 lớp năng lực và các em
có đầu tư hệ thống phần cứng.
Thì các em sẽ phải đi khảo sát thị trường
về các thiết bị phần cứng,
em định dự kiến làm và lập ra danh mục
mua sắm,
đầu tư và chọn nhà thầu và để em định.
Cái điện toán,
cái giá chi phí người sẽ phải đầu tư lập
ngân sách,
rồi kích hoạt nghiệm thu vận hành,
một luật cơ bản đối với một cái dự án đầu
tư hạ tầng gồm có các mục như sau.
Là các cái bước phía trên của mình là
những bước nội dung của em sẽ làm là các
nội dung cơ bản và thường phải có trong
một cái dự án đầu tư.
Còn cái phần mà trình bày lại thì cô nói
giống như các thuyết minh đầu tư hoặc là
các thuyết minh phát triển phần mềm.
Dự án đầu tư thì mỗi bên sẽ có một cái
trang web khác nhau.
Nếu sau này mình đi làm ở đâu thì người
ta có internet gì thì viết đúng cái trang
web của người ta.
Như thường thì những cái nội dung mà cần
phải có để các em viết vô mấy cái đó thì
chỉ là nội dung trong 12 bức.
Mà cô gửi ở đây còn từ cái nội dung đó,
các em chuẩn sắp xếp và các em hiệu chỉnh
cái báo cáo hoặc em có bổ sung thêm nội
dung gì đó thì tùy theo cái.
Quyết định của nhóm để các em chọn cái tư
tự báo cáo phù hợp,
còn không có thì các em có thể dựa theo
cái mục lục.
Về phần báo cáo mà cô viết ở đây các em
dễ trình bày.
những.
Chứ còn cái việc mà em chỉ khảo sát rồi
đưa ra input rồi ra output không thì nó
đâu phải là đồ án,
đồ án là 50% được mà các em.
Hiểu không này.
Việc cái phần đồ án thì mình sẽ giả lập
giống như là em giả lập cái tình trạng là
công ty đó đang gặp vấn đề về cái một
mảng nào đó.
Thì bên em giả lập cái tình huống và các
dự kiến đầu tư.
Đúng không
Dự kiến đúng rồi,
dự kiến những lớp năng lực nào các em sẽ
đầu tư.
Dự kiến các lớp năng lực,
các em sẽ đầu tư như lớp năng lực thu
trong chương 2 này,
phần bài tập cô giáo hôm nay nè.
Ừ
Ừ.
Rồi kem trong hai lớp,
những lớp năng lực em đầu tư đó,
em đầu tư hết tất cả các thành phần hay
là em chỉ giống như hồi nãy cô mới sửa
vài bạn giống pha xa với các bạn đó làm
khá là ổn đó. Các bạn cho ba thành phần,
các bạn đầu tư theo trong hai lớp năng
lực đó thôi.
Và các bạn đang giả lập là cái hiện trạng
công ty đó đang có vấn đề ở 3 cái thành
phần đó ở 2 lớp năng lực này nên bây giờ
em sẽ quyết định đầu tư và nâng cao,
nâng cấp cái hệ thống,
nâng cấp cái hạ tầng của doanh nghiệp ở
tại.
Cái phạm vi đó.
Hiểu không?
Còn vậy là cái phần đồ án là mình giả lập
cái rồi mình nâng cấp hạ tầng được lên
Ừ
lớp năng lực đúng không?
Còn cái phần thực hành là mình sẽ đi sâu
Đúng rồi.
vào công nghệ.
Thực hành là mình đi sâu vô cái phần mềm
phát triển và cái phần mềm thì nó sẽ đi
theo một cái quy trình nghiệp vụ.
Các em chọn một quy trình nghiệp vụ ở
trong cái doanh nghiệp các em chọn.
Và em sẽ xây dựng cái phần mềm hỗ trợ cho
cái quy trình nghiệp vụ đó mà bây giờ
À
mình sẽ có ứng dụng công nghệ mới.
Sau khi em ứng dụng công nghệ mới thì cái
phần mềm ứng dụng đó nó không dừng ở mức
quản lý mà nó có thể có chức năng an toàn
hơn.
Cá nhân hóa tốt hơn hoặc là thông minh
hơn,
chẳng hạn thì cái đó là do cái em lựa
chọn cái công nghệ mà các em làm công
nghệ đó đem lại lợi ích gì?
À dạ.
không.
Vậy là vậy là em cảm ơn cô.
Ừ.
Hồi nãy cô la, cô ấy video,
cô có ví dụ cho một cái 2 một cái chức
năng về ứng dụng công nghệ mới trong quy
trình khám chữa bệnh tại bệnh viện mà bây
giờ các nghiên cứu ở các cái nghiên cứu
cơ bản đang tiến hành.
Triển khai ở bệnh viện chưa có,
nhưng mà các nghiên cứu cơ bản hiện nay
đang làm cái đó nhiều lắm luôn á,
là nhóm đầu tư được ưu tiên đầu tư luôn á
để phát triển.
Dạ em một nhóm 8 thì đầu tiên là em muốn
đổi tên của cái đề tài của em của nhóm em
đang có là.
Đăng ký chưa em?
Dạ em có ghi lại ở trong phần bài post
rồi có cái tên đề tài.
Và em muốn cô Trịnh.
Bài bố của em anh nói tới đâu.
Dạ em chỉ mới chỉnh,
em chỉ mới chỉnh sửa thôi,
còn cô muốn lấy cái tên nhanh á thì cô
vào phần drive của nhóm em có.
Cô còn nghe tin đây thức em.
Em máy.
Dạ.
Dạ, nhóm 8.
Và phần tiếp theo là em muốn.
Chưa em đã cơ sở hết.
Dạ
Nếu 4
Nếu 111.
nhóm về.
Linh 5 sáng.
Những 8 này của em đúng không?
Dạ đúng ạ.
Bữa trước cô dặn là có sữa thì lấy cái
mới để ra nó xuống cái phía dưới cô dễ
kiếm nha các em. Nhất lần thứ mấy rồi.
Dạ.
Anh em chủ nhật, dạ nhóm 8 ạ.
Nhưng mà nhớ máy.
Em sửa nhanh nhưng mà cô sửa không có
nhanh.
Dạ.
Và bây giờ ai là người quản lý,
cô là người quản lý thì em phải làm cho
cô xử lý nhanh cho vấn đề của mình chứ.
Đúng không?
Dạ vâng, dạ vâng, dạ em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi còn chuyện gì nữa em?
Dạ phần tiếp theo là nhóm em muốn nhờ cơ
sở về phần bài tập xác định phạm vi đề
xuất ạ.
Cái nào vậy?
Dạ,
em có tách ra phần thành phần báo cáo
nhóm 8 mà cô và phần báo cáo nhóm 8 giúp
em ạ.
Hồi nãy cô có hướng dẫn một nhóm rồi,
cô biết em và biết nhóm mình phải làm gì
Dạ.
không?
Dạ em có gộp vào sẵn rồi,
nhưng mà cái file kia nó hơi dài nên
trong tay nó có trong cái phần quanh tay
nó nhanh hơn ạ.
Hồi nãy,
cô có hướng dẫn cho nhóm kia thông báo
nhóm kia rồi em biết nhóm mình đang bị
lỗi gì không?
Dạ em biết,
dạ em biết em để nhiều file quá.
Là cái gì? Đúng rồi,
cái nào chỉ là phải phụ thì gom vô funder
rap hoặc là person on oversen.
Để cái mới nhất của hoàng là file thôi hả
Dạ vâng.
em? Là cái này mới nhất đúng không?
Dạ dạ.
Dạ
Phạm vi đầu tư cái này là các em.
Dạ, thưa cô,
là tại vì trong nhóm em có một thành viên
là cũng đang làm bên cái dự án này luôn á.
Cô không có mấy em nhớ là đừng có phân
biệt rõ giữa cái yêu cầu của bài tập với
việc các em lấy một cái dự án có thể vô
nha các em.
Thí dụ yêu cầu bài tập ở đây giống như
bài tập của yêu cầu là trong cái mô hình
trong lớp này nè.
Em sẽ chọn lớp nào thì ở đây là kem,
nhóm mình chọn đúng rồi là các em có thể
chọn và chọn phạm vi của mẫu rồi là lớp
một và lớp 4. Và trong lớp 1,
lớp 4 thì các em xác định cho cô rõ cái
phạm vi đầu tư là các em sẽ đầu tư các
thành phần nào trong lớp 1 với lớp 4.
Theo các môn học của mình.
Và các em xác định đúng thì cái đó chứ
không phải các em liệt kê theo một cái dự
án mà các em đang nằm để vào đây thì nó
không có đáp ứng yêu cầu của mô học này.
Hình Quân.
Dạ em có ạ.
Biết biết cái biết cái nội dung cho
chương khai này đúng không?
Dạ vâng ạ
Thì giờ nhớ mình chỉnh lại cái chỗ này.
Thí dụ ở đây, cái em,
thí dụ các bạn của em đều có kinh nghiệm
làm cái này thì coi mấy cái thiết bị mà
các em đang chọn đây là nằm trong thành
phần nào của hai cái lớp mà các em đã
chọn.
Thì các em có thể chọn gần nó rồi,
các em có thể tìm hiểu sâu hơn,
có thể là cái phạm vi đầu tư của mình.
Nó là nguyên cái thành phần thì nó có bên
cạnh mấy cái thông tin cơ bản này,
nó có thể nhiều nhiều cái phần đầu tư hơn.
Trong các thành phần đó,
các em trình bày đầy đủ để đáp ứng nhu
cầu của môn học.
Dạ vâng, dạ em sẽ ghi nhận và chỉnh sửa ạ.
Dạ em cám ơn cô.
Ừ.
Rồi vậy
Hiện.
Dạ em chào cô thì nhóm em có câu hỏi đó
là em có câu trả lời nhưng mà không biết
nó đúng không?
Nhưng em nhờ cô xác nhận là dùm đó là tại
vì trước đó nhóm em bị hiểu nhầm về cái
yêu cầu giữa bài đồ án và bài thực hành
đó cô nhóm em hiểu là cái phần thực hành
nó sẽ.
Là mở rộng và nói tiếp,
có liên kết với lại đồ án,
nhưng mà trong quá trình nãy giờ nghe cô
giảng thì nhóm em có hiểu là cái phần
thực hành nó sẽ là một cái bài độc lập
chỉ là thực hiện cùng trên một cái đối
tượng mà mình chọn chung với bài đồ án
thôi thì như vậy có đúng không cô?
Và với lại nhóm em muốn hỏi là về cái.
Những cái bài báo cáo cũng như là trình
bày sau này của cả 2 bài đồ án và thực
hành thì nó sẽ hoàn toàn độc lập với nhau
đúng không cô?
Ừ rồi về cái này nè,
thế cái kỳ vọng của cô thường là cô sẽ
**** muốn là bài đồ án với bài tình hình
nó sẽ có liên kết giống như giả sử trong
cái đồ án là em có đăng ký 2 lớp và trong
lớp đó các em có đầu tư.
Từ thành phần phần mềm.
Thì đối với các bài thực hành thì mình sẽ
triển khai cụ thể cái thành vật phần mềm
ứng dụng mà phần mềm,
phần mềm ứng dụng trong cái thành phần
phần mềm mà mình đã chọn bên đồ án để
mình làm tiếp.
Nếu được thì làm vậy,
còn không thì các em liền có thể chọn độc
Dạ.
lập được luôn là cô cho các em 2 sự lựa
chọn lúc nào cũng được.
Nhạc.
Là cái phần mềm của em có thể chọn một
cái quy trình nghiệp vụ độc lập và các em
xây dựng cái phần mềm cho một cái quy
trình nghiệp vụ đó luôn.
Cái nếu mà chọn theo cái đó thì kem dễ
làm rồi.
Dạ.
Còn cái phần mà báo cáo trình bày sau này
thì 2 cái phần này độc lập của em cho 2
Dạ.
cột điểm khác nhau.
Báo cáo là trong các em coi phần hướng
dẫn thực hành với hướng dẫn đồ án.
Mỗi cái nó có yêu cầu sản phẩm phải báo
cáo, rồi video báo cáo slide thuyết trình.
Thì đó là mỗi bài thực hành một bộ là sẽ
có một báo cáo.
Một video thuyết trình,
một sẽ là thuyết trình bài thực hành cũng
vậy.
Và cô sẽ chấm riêng cho hàng cột điểm này.
Dạ dạ vâng ạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi nhấn Thiện xong thì tắt tắt giơ tay.
Đây có biết bạn nào xong bạn nào chưa?
Tiếp theo phong.
Em cho cô bảo là em Giang muốn hỏi là khi
mà mình chọn cái a gọi là một cái a
phương án đầu tư cho cái ba phần thực
hành ý ạ thì có lưu ý gì về cái.
Cách mình chọn đúng không ạ?
Ví dụ như là bọn em đang.
Cách mình chọn
Nói đi em.
Ở ví dụ như như bạn,
bọn em đang phân vân giữa 2 cái vấn đề là
một cái ứng dụng,
một cái là đầu tư về cái mảng vân tay phe
ID cho nhân viên.
Và một cái là chatbot tư vấn bán hàng.
Thì thì nếu mà 2 cái lựa chọn này thì thì
nó cần có lưu ý gì không ạ?
Tức là một trong 2 ý ạ.
Cái hai cái đó đều là hai cái phần mềm
ứng dụng cả đều là hai cái phần mềm ứng
Nếu như mà mình chọn.
dụng.
Còn chỉ có khác là thí dụ cái bên kia là
em là file ID đúng không?
Thì em dự kiến là em nghiên cứu cái bài
toán Face đi cho quy trình nghiệp vụ nào.
Thí dụ giống như cô đưa ra một ví dụ
giống như là ở trường đại học đi,
trường đại học cũng cần có Face ID và một
số trường đại học mà Tiến tiếp trên thế
giới là người ta có cái chế độ là một số
dự án gọi là điểm danh.
Điểm danh là không cần,
mình phải làm gì hết,
chỉ cần sinh viên xuất hiện trong không
gian trường là các camera sẽ tự động tích
hợp fail đi và xác nhận rằng bạn này có
đi học hay không và đi tiến hành điểm
danh.
Nếu một số trường có quy định khắt khe về
cái việc điểm danh.
Nếu mà bạn đó vắng quá 1 phần 3 cái thời
lượng học thì bạn sẽ bị cấm thi chẳng hạn
thì một số trường nó sẽ triển khai triển
khai fairs AD thông qua camera.
Nếu mà em chọn làm fail đi hoặc làm một
số.
Chỉ có phây đi thôi,
còn còn một số cái trường đại học,
còn kiểu làm lớp học thông minh,
đó là deate cái hành động học tập của
sinh viên luôn để đánh giá luôn thì cái
này là nó đều dừng ở demo thôi chứ ứng
dụng thì người ta chưa đem vô nhiều face
face đi thì có ứng dụng rồi.
Thì nếu mà em muốn làm cái đó thì em phải
miêu tả cái ứng,
cái công nghệ fair đi mà em muốn áp dụng
vô cái quy trình nghiệp vụ nào.
Thí dụ giống như cái trường đại học em
cũng nói là quy trình dùng để điểm cho
anh tự động để dành cho sinh viên để giám
sát học tập,
nâng cao quá trình học tập thì em.
Đặt ra vấn đề là trong quá trình quản lý
giáo dục ở các trường đại học thì cái
việc mà có cái việc là hoạt động học tập
của sinh viên thì còn khó kiểm soát và do
cái sự phụ thuộc vào sự tự giác của sinh
viên.
Sinh viên lên thì cái sự tự giác không
còn gia đình quản lý,
dẫn đến cái tỷ lệ rất tốt nghiệp,
không tham gia học,
không tham gia học tập đầy đủ rồi.
Nhà trường khó phát hiện là bạn nào đang
bỏ học nhiều nên dẫn đến cái tỷ lệ học
tập đang đi xuống và tỷ lệ rớt tốt nghiệp
đi xuống.
Nên dẫn đến em muốn cải tiến cái quy
trình quản lý hoạt động học tập của sinh
viên,
và trong đó là thay vì các quản lý trên
các cái hoạt động học tập bình thường thì
mình sẽ quản lý điểm danh để.
Áp dụng cho sinh viên đó là giống như cái
ngữ cảnh em đặt ra.
Hình như mấy cô nói,
các em làm theo cái đó thì vẫn được.
Đó là một cái cô đưa ra một ví dụ về một
quy trình nghiệp vụ.
Và cái vấn đề hiện tại thì người ta đang
có quản lý cái cơ bản.
Nhưng mà bây giờ nếu mà mình quản lý cái
mình đưa thêm công nghệ mới.
Ứng dụng file ID gọi là để xử lý dữ liệu
video trên camera chẳng hạn,
cái bài toán nó xử lý video camera thì nó
dự đoán tốt hơn sẽ làm cho hệ thống hoạt
động tốt hơn.
Thông minh hơn chẳng hạn cải thiện được
cái hiệu suất hoạt động quản lý của quy
trình nghiệp vụ đó.
Thì bài thực bài phần mềm bài thực hành
này các em chỉ cần đặt ra một cái quy
trình đó và em đi sâu về nó là được.
Còn hồi nãy đặt cái gì nữa ta,
cái bài đó ý thứ 2 là cái gì?
Ý thứ 2 con nhớ nó cũng nghiệp vụ thôi,
đúng không?
Ý thứ 2 thì là liên quan đến customer
service được sử dụng AI chatbot ạ.
À, chatbot nó cũng ngừng tương tự thôi,
thì em đặt ra một cái quy trình giống như
là chăm sóc khách hàng.
Thì bây giờ em muốn phát triển một cái
chai,
chatbot nào tốt hơn để phục vụ cho người
dùng tiếng Việt và có thể xử lý các cái
dữ liệu.
Ừm mình chuyên cho người Việt và.
Mình do người việt làm chủ,
nhưng mà ở đây tôi nói rất chatbot là nếu
mà các em xây dựng ở đây là cô đang kỳ
văn nếu các em.
Làm chủ công nghệ là xây dựng các chất
bối dành cho người Việt và có thể tự xử
lý được để mà tại vì có một số cái văn
bản hoặc là thông tin thì kiểu mang tính
chất bảo mật mà mình không có nên mình
không có gọi IBI được nha hay là sử dụng
của bên thứ 3 được?
Mà mình phải tự xây dựng để kiểm soát.
Thì nếu mà các em đi theo cái hướng đó
thì các em có thể gọi chăm sóc khách hàng,
nhưng mà là mình tìm hiểu về quy trình xử
lý dữ liệu NLP để xây dựng trách móc dành
cho người Việt để làm cái.
Công áp dụng công nghệ mới xử lý của tự
nhiên dành cho tiếng Việt.
Thì cái dự án của mình bài bài,
bài thực hành của mình mới đạt chuẩn nha.
Còn cái việc mà chỉ gọi API dựa trên mấy
cái của thằng Chessi PT hoặc Sermani có
sẵn gọi về xài thôi á,
thì cái đó là em xài API thôi chứ em có
áp dụng công nghệ mới gì đâu.
Em đâu có tự xây dựng hoặc là triển khai
mình mới.
Thì cái đó không tính, cái đó là được.
Hai hướng hướng nào cũng được,
nhưng mà mình phải tìm hiểu quy trình
Dạ vâng
triển khai nó.
Và cho em hỏi một câu nữa là cái bài thực
hành này,
Rồi rồi.
ví dụ như là em đang đặt ra một cái hướng
để mà em đầu tư và trong cái hướng đó có.
Những cái lớp năng lực mà nó khác so với
cái lớp năng lực mà ở bên a bài ờ cái bài
đồ án mà hiện tại nhóm đang làm ý ạ.
Thực hành mình chỉ là phần mềm thôi,
em thực hành chỉ là phần mềm thôi,
coi hướng dẫn thực hành này kỹ lại,
thực hành nó có đầu tư lớp nào.
Thực hành chỉ là phát triển hệ thống phần
mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới thôi.
À ạ
Là phần mềm ở cấp độ nghiệp vụ á.
Phạm vi và thực hành phần mềm và cấp đồng
nghiệp vụ.
Rồi phong xong rồi có thể tắt.
Cậu em nhóm 4 câu,
em nhờ cô xem lại giúp em cái bài.
Ừ
Hôm bữa là cô có đánh giá là về bài hành
thì OK nhưng mà còn về.
Đồ án thì chưa đủ yêu cầu,
em có cập nhật thêm các ý.
Cái quy trình với cho đối với đối tượng
cái lợi ích cho cái đối tượng.
Hoàng.
Có xem giúp em trang 3 cô xem giúp em
trang 3.
Là cái mục nào trong máy đây?
Trạch từ đầu tư năng lực nào cô?
Ngày lớp 1 với lớp 5 sao tự nhiên ở đây
cái em gọi là nhớ đi.
Cái ngành lớp 1 với lớp 5 rồi.
Là kem chọn lớp 1 với lớp 5.
Dạ đúng rồi.
Tôi vậy, vì sao phải là lớp 1, lớp 5,
em đưa ra lý do để đầu tư lớp 1,
lớp 5 đâu?
Vào đây các em mới có xác định lớp này và
nhóm đối tượng thôi.
Còn lý do vì sao mình phải đầu tư 2 lớp
này thì mình chưa nói rõ.
Dạ vậy
Ở phía dưới có cái chỗ quy trình nó có về
để tối ưu về quản lý kho cho các cửa hàng.
Còn cái lớp 1 là để 1,
thứ 1 là phục vụ cho lớp 5 là để.
Bộ dữ liệu ổn định với.
Mở rộng cái chi nhánh đồng bộ nhanh hơn.
Vì cái hiện trạng hiện tại nó như thế nào,
mình phải miêu tả luôn.
Hồi nãy cô có nói cái bài tập ngày hôm
nay em nhớ không?
Dạ.
Khảo sát hiện trạng thì bây giờ hiện
trạng của lớp 1,
lớp 5 họ cái công ty của các em chọn công
viên công ty gì Long Châu, FPT Long Châu,
hiện trạng của lớp 1,
lớp 5 nó đang có các vấn đề gì thì các em
cần phải nêu nó ra.
Dạ,
cái này ở em có trên cái trang trang một
cô.
Và cuối tháng 1, cái chỗ vấn đề đặt ra.
Nếu mà mình làm á thì ngay trong cái ở
đây hình như cô nhớ cái quan Score.
Trong bao lâu,
đầu tư năng cho đối tượng nào,
nhân lực nào? Ok, cái này không có.
Nếu như mà một số nhóm là có trình bày và
nếu mà được thì trong một trang đầu tiên,
em có thể nói ngắn gọn ở đây.
Mình có thể nói ngắn gọn ở đây trong một
trang còn không thì mình có cái hiện
trạng thì em nên nêu cái hiện trạng từ
ban đầu hoặc là ở đây em có nêu rồi đúng
không?
Vấn đề đặt ra của lớp 1 ở đâu?
Chả có nêu nhưng mà không có nằm trong
cái trang này.
Tao vấn vấn đề của lớp 1 lớp 5 đâu ngày
hôm nay ở đâu?
Dạ, cô xem đi em.
Là cái phần mà dự kiến mở rộng thêm nhiều
điểm bán cô thì việc.
Ở đâu?
Chỗ nào.
Và ở cuối trang 1, cuối trang 1.
À không,
cái này tụi em viết chung chung mà chứ
chưa có clip rõ ràng à cái này nè.
Thì các em viết chung chung,
các em viết chung nó chưa có rõ mà.
Thí vụ các em muốn.
Dạ để.
Giả sử các em muốn nói là các em lớp 1,
lớp 5 á thì hồi nãy có thấy tin nhớ lớp
pha xa cô sữa là các bạn làm cái ổn đó.
Mình sẽ nêu ngữ cảnh ngắn gọn và mình sẽ
nói hiện trạng lớp 1 lớp 5 của.
FPT trong châu đang gặp vấn đề gì?
Do đó,
nếu mà kem không viết được gọn trong một
trang.
Nếu nhúng trước các nhúng trước thì các
em viết riêng cũng được.
Thì cái phần viết riêng ở chỗ này.
Em cũng phải nêu nó một cách cụ thể chứ
không có viết chung chung vậy.
Người ta đâu biết đây là các vấn đề của
lớp 1 và lớp 5.
Hay của lúc nào?
Hiểu nếu mà kem muốn làm.
Dạ cô dạ dạ.
Để chỗ này đấy nhé, em trình bày kỹ lại.
Còn.
Ừ rồi đầu tư thì ổn rồi.
Dạ con dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Kho tổng chi nhánh,
chi nhánh nhận hàng bán tốt,
tạm thời cũng ổn nhưng mà viết gọn lại
với lại cụ thể vô được.
Dạ dạ, cảm ơn cô.
Rồi.
Nếu sao mình tắt giơ tay em để cô biết.
Rồi nếu không còn vấn đề gì nữa thì về
các nhóm phân công công việc và thực hiện
2 cái này nha các em.
Tới buổi học tiếp theo là ngày 3 tháng 9
thì các nhóm sẽ trình bày về cái nội dung
mà các em, đồ án và thực hành,
các em dự kiến làm thêm.
Rồi buổi học mình kết thúc ở đây.